What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Welcome to Second Drink, The Return, this episode, Ed Helms, is our guest.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购到大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单0美元的配送费。服务费、除外条款和条款适用。Instacart，超值配送的杂货。欢迎来到《第二杯》，《回归》这一集，我们的嘉宾是艾德·赫尔姆斯。
Yes, and we also hear from Greg Daniels about the inspiration for the return and how he structured the storyline. You know, we discussed in our original breakdown, we shot Traveling Salesman and the Return as one big episode. Yeah. So there are a lot of fun behind-the-scenes details in this one. But before we get going, let's start the second drink with some great fan background catches.
是的，我们还听取了格雷格·丹尼尔斯关于《回归》的灵感来源以及他如何构建故事情节的讲述。你知道，我们在最初的解析中讨论过，我们将《旅行推销员》和《回归》作为一整集来拍摄。是的。所以这一集里有很多有趣的幕后细节。但在我们开始之前，让我们先用一些很棒的粉丝捕捉到的背景信息来开启《第二杯》。
You know, we love it when John says, the white. Mm-hmm. And M. N. Cunningham commented that there is a great, the white, in Jim's first talking head. It comes right after Andy is singing and driving him crazy. Let's hear it. So here's to the future. Andy and the tuna.
你知道，我们很喜欢约翰说“那个白人”的时候。嗯哼。M.N.坎宁安评论说，在吉姆的第一个谈话头中有一个很棒的“那个白人”。就在安迪唱歌让他抓狂之后。让我们听听看。所以，为了未来。安迪和金枪鱼。
Yeah, Andy and the tuna. Oh, but a to know, magical. Andy and the tuna. I miss Dwight. Congratulations, universe. You win. That's a full Dwight. It is a full Dwight.
是的，安迪和金枪鱼。哦，但是金枪鱼，太神奇了。安迪和金枪鱼。我想念德怀特。恭喜你，宇宙。你赢了。那是一个完整的德怀特。确实是一个完整的德怀特。
That's crazy. I also just love the talking head because Jim, Jim can't believe he's actually missing Dwight. Well, listen, we also had a lot of people right in to say we missed a great guest actor shout out. I actually ended up talking about this in our episode Revisited with Randall Einhorn, but I'm bringing it back here, Jesse M. and many other. shared that the woman at Staples that Dwight asks if she needs help is credited as woman, and that person is Charlotte Stewart who played Miss Beatle on Little House on the Prairie.
太疯狂了。我也很喜欢那个谈话头，因为吉姆，吉姆简直不敢相信他竟然在想念德怀特。好吧，听着，我们还有很多人写信来说我们错过了一个很棒的客串演员的致敬。我实际上在我们的《重访》剧集中和兰德尔·艾因霍恩谈过这件事，但我现在要把它带回来，杰西·M和其他许多人分享说，在史泰博，德怀特问她是否需要帮助的那位女士，演职员表上写的是“女士”，那个人是夏洛特·斯图尔特，她在《草原小屋》中饰演比德尔小姐。
Jesse went on to say this may be a fun fact. Only the older generation can appreciate, but I want to say, Jesse, thank you so much for pointing this out. Yes, and you know, I guess that makes two Little House on the Prairie crossovers with the office. Because of Malora Hardin. That's right. Well, this next fan catch cracked me up. Madeline Kay wrote,
杰西接着说，这可能是一个只有老一辈人才能欣赏的有趣事实，但我想说，杰西，非常感谢你指出这一点。是的，你知道，我想这使得《办公室》与《草原小屋》有了两次联动。因为马洛拉·哈丁。没错。好吧，下一个粉丝捕捉到的点让我笑喷了。玛德琳·凯写道，
It makes sense that the nard dog graces us with his presence on National Dog Day. Every year, August 26th is National Dog Day. Oh, wow. So you got a lot of nard dog on August 26, 2020. Well, in this episode, I shared how we made all of the snow that was falling outside of the windows. We even posted a picture of the snow sifter that we used. You all sent in so much mail. So many people were curious about it
“纳德狗”在“全国狗狗日”用他的存在来装点我们，这很有道理。每年的8月26日是全国狗狗日。哦，哇。所以你在2020年8月26日看到了很多“纳德狗”。好吧，在这一集中，我分享了我们是如何制作窗外飘落的所有雪的。我们甚至发布了一张我们使用的筛雪机的照片。你们寄来了这么多邮件。很多人对此感到好奇，
and made me so happy because I really was so interested in this falling snow. A big thank you to Chris H for writing and to say, just listening to this episode and had to find the picture of the snow sifter immediately
这让我非常高兴，因为我真的对这些飘落的雪非常感兴趣。非常感谢克里斯·H写信来说，刚听完这一集，就不得不立刻找到筛雪机的照片，
while on the train toward home from work and it did not disappoint. People were very happy about that. Well, I big thank you to Kentapedia for giving me the picture. Yeah. Lastly, I want to show
当时正在下班回家的火车上，它没有让人失望。人们对此非常高兴。好吧，非常感谢肯塔佩迪亚给我这张照片。是的。最后，我想展示，
share a deleted scene. We didn't even discuss the first time. It's just one of those great small moments that I love. So, you know, Oscar has come back to work and he is sitting in the break room and Toby pops his head in to say hello. They haven't seen each other in a while. They're going to kind of catch up, right? Yeah. This conversation is hilarious. You have to hear it. Hey, Oscar. How's Europe? It was great. Yeah? A lot of pictures. Oh, great. You? Well, my daughter turned seven. Oh, so, yeah, big party, lots of pictures. Nice.
分享一个我们第一次甚至没有讨论过的删减片段。这只是我喜欢的那些伟大的小瞬间之一。所以，你知道，奥斯卡回到工作岗位，他坐在休息室里，托比探出头来打招呼。他们已经有一段时间没见了。他们要叙叙旧，对吧？是的。这段对话太搞笑了。你一定要听听。嘿，奥斯卡。欧洲怎么样？很棒。是吗？拍了很多照片。哦，太棒了。你呢？嗯，我女儿七岁了。哦，所以，是的，盛大的派对，拍了很多照片。不错。
Yeah, that's nice. Thanks. So should we email the pictures to each other? Or? I don't think we have to do that. Okay. All right. So they both say they took lots of pictures of these two events in their lives,
是的，那很好。谢谢。那我们应该把照片发给对方吗？或者？我不认为我们必须那样做。好的。好吧。所以他们都说他们为生活中的这两件事拍了很多照片，
and then that's it. Do you want to see them? Nah. I'm good. I don't know. It just cracked me up. That is very funny. All right, you guys, well, now it's time for your second drink of the return. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Welcome. Welcome back to The Return.
然后就这样了。你想看吗？不。我很好。我不知道。这只是让我笑喷了。那非常有趣。好吧，伙计们，现在是时候喝你们的《回归》第二杯了。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。欢迎。欢迎回到《回归》。
We're returning with the return. Do you see what we did there? See that? I like that. We're geniuses. No one can top us. Guys, this is Season 3, Episode 13. This was written by Gene Stupnitzky, Lee Eisenberg, and Michael Shore, and directed by Greg Daniels.
我们带着《回归》回归了。你看到我们做了什么吗？看到了吗？我喜欢那个。我们是天才。没人能超越我们。伙计们，这是第三季第13集。这是由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基、李·艾森伯格和迈克尔·肖尔编写，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。
Jenna, let's have a summary. All right, here we go. Oscar returns to work. He's returning from his vacation to an elaborate Mexican theme party that he didn't ask for and doesn't really want. That sounds about right. With Dwight gone, Andy fights hard to win Michael's favor, but crosses the line. Jim and Pam team up to prank Andy and ultimately bait him into an angry meltdown. When Michael learns from Angela that Dwight's supposed disloyalty was actually just a misunderstanding, he goes to Staples to win Dwight back. And Dwight returns. It's a double return. And there it is. It's a double return. Jenna, I feel like if we were to title this episode from Angela Martin's point of view,
珍娜，让我们来个总结。好的，我们开始吧。奥斯卡回到工作岗位。他从假期回来，面对一个他没要求也不想要的精心策划的墨西哥主题派对。听起来很对。德怀特走了，安迪努力争取迈克尔的青睐，但越界了。吉姆和帕姆联手恶作剧安迪，最终诱使他情绪崩溃。当迈克尔从安吉拉那里得知德怀特所谓的背叛实际上只是一个误会时，他去史泰博把德怀特赢了回来。德怀特回来了。这是一个双重回归。就是这样。这是一个双重回归。珍娜，我觉得如果我们从安吉拉·马丁的角度来给这一集命名，
I would like to title it Snow and Sadness. There are so many Snowflowers. lakes and tears falling in this episode. There's some serious moping and snow. Yeah. It's so true. Well, Angela, that leads me very well to fast fact number one, which I called it's snowing in Scranton. It was such a fun backdrop to the whole episode. I know.
我想把它命名为《雪与悲伤》。这一集里有太多的雪花、湖泊和泪水。有一些严重的忧郁和积雪。是的。太真实了。好吧，安吉拉，这很好地引出了我的第一个速记事实，我称之为“斯克兰顿下雪了”。这是整集非常有趣的背景。我知道。
We also got a lot of fan questions about it. Elisa Schroeder, Mariana Gonzalez, Holly Gannett, and Paige Carter all. said in this episode, it is constantly snowing. How did you do it? Was there a video there? Did they use a green screen? Well, I mean, I think we all know who I asked about this. Please tell me you hit up Kentapedia. Oh, lady, you know I did. And you know he delivered because he's amazing. Kent Zabornak, thank you so much for always being there for us. So first of all, on one of the first pages in the script, there is this note. And it says, through the window, we see that it is snow. Michael doesn't notice. It should be snowing throughout the entire episode. So this was noted in the script. The writers came up with this idea. It's going to pay off when Michael's car fills with snow. But we also just used to like to represent the season that the show would be in when it aired. So even though we shot this in October, it was going to air in like January or February. It would be winter and Scranton. I love it. I love that throughout the episode, you see people, like,
我们也收到了很多关于它的粉丝提问。埃莉萨·施罗德、玛丽安娜·冈萨雷斯、霍莉·加内特和佩奇·卡特都说，在这一集中，它一直在下雪。你们是怎么做到的？那里有视频吗？他们用了绿幕吗？好吧，我的意思是，我想我们都知道我问了谁。请告诉我你联系了肯塔佩迪亚。哦，女士，你知道我联系了。而且你知道他做到了，因为他太棒了。肯特·扎博纳克，非常感谢你一直为我们服务。所以首先，在剧本的前几页之一，有这个注释。它说，透过窗户，我们看到那是雪。迈克尔没有注意到。整集都应该在下雪。所以这在剧本中被注明了。编剧们想出了这个主意。当迈克尔的车里装满雪时，它会得到回报。但我们也只是喜欢用它来代表节目播出时所处的季节。所以即使我们在十月拍摄，它也会在一月或二月左右播出。那将是斯克兰顿的冬天。我喜欢它。我喜欢在整集中，你看到人们，比如，
like having talking heads and it's just coming down. I just love that little detail. Well, here is what we did to make it snow in those talking heads, Angela. We used the same company that we used in the Christmas episode, the first Christmas episode, remember them? Snow business? Mm-hmm. And they used this very old-fashioned technique.
比如进行谈话头，雪就在落下。我只是喜欢那个小细节。好吧，这就是我们为了让那些谈话头下雪所做的事情，安吉拉。我们使用了我们在圣诞节那一集，第一个圣诞节那一集使用的同一家公司，记得他们吗？雪生意？嗯哼。他们使用了这种非常老式的技术。
He said they've been using it for decades and they still use it today. They take like a large roller and they put it behind the window and it has. and it has like, what's the thing that you put your pasta in to drain it? Or like a sifter when you do powdered sugar? Yes, so it's a giant rolling sifter that they fill with snow and then they just crank it. There's like a dude back there cranking fake snow like through a giant sifter? Yeah, there can be a dude or a lady or it can be on a little motor. It just spins endlessly and snow falls out of it until you.
他说他们几十年来一直使用它，今天仍然在使用。他们拿一个大滚筒，把它放在窗户后面，它有。它有像，你放意大利面去沥干的东西是什么？或者像你做糖粉时用的筛子？是的，所以这是一个巨大的滚动筛子，他们装满雪，然后他们只是转动它。后面有一个家伙在转动假雪，通过一个巨大的筛子？是的，可以有一个男的或女的，或者它可以在一个小马达上。它只是无休止地旋转，雪从里面掉出来，直到你。
fill it again. And he even sent me a picture of it. So I will put it up on our office ladies pod Instagram. Oh, I want to see that picture. Yeah. And then the same company snow business would come and put all the snow and ice on the ground. And they had this big blower machine where they would like blow it all over the bushes. I remember the blower machine, but I don't think I ever went back behind where the windows were, where we did talking heads. And I never got to see the sifter. Well, there's a little gap. You know, there's like the wall and then there's a gap. And then there's a gap, and then there's that Scranton backdrop that we would also change seasonally. So we had a snowy backdrop, and then we had a little sifter fellow.
再次装满它。他甚至给我发了一张照片。所以我把它放在我们的《办公室女士》播客Instagram上。哦，我想看那张照片。是的。然后同一家公司“雪生意”会来把所有的雪和冰放在地上。他们有这台大鼓风机，他们会把它吹到灌木丛上。我记得那台鼓风机，但我不认为我曾经去过窗户后面的地方，我们在那里做谈话头。我从来没有机会看到那个筛子。好吧，有一个小缝隙。你知道，有墙，然后有一个缝隙。然后有一个缝隙，然后有那个斯克兰顿背景，我们也会季节性地更换。所以我们有一个下雪的背景，然后我们有一个小筛子家伙。
Our sifter person. Yeah, exactly. Well, I love that fast fact. Well, fast fact number two, Angela, remember last week we talked about how this episode and traveling salesmen were shot as one big episode. And our director of this episode and our showrunner, Greg Daniel, sent in a bunch of audio clips where he mentioned some of the inspiration for these two episodes. Well, he did it again. And he sent in an audio clip about some of the things that they were juggling for this portion
我们的筛子人。是的，完全正确。好吧，我喜欢那个速记事实。好吧，第二个速记事实，安吉拉，记得上周我们谈到这一集和《旅行推销员》是如何作为一整集拍摄的吗？我们这一集的导演和我们的剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯发来了一堆音频片段，他在其中提到了这两集的一些灵感来源。好吧，他又做了。他发来了一个音频片段，关于他们为这一部分所权衡的一些事情，
of the storyline. So Sam, will you play that clip? These were like extremely complex storylines. There was a lot of good stuff between Pam and Angela, between Dwight and Angela, between Michael and Dwight. And these stories brought in lots of cards that we had on the boards. One of the things that we would do in pre-production is we would generate all these funny ideas for different storylines or fragments or B stories and they would become note cards that would be push pinned into the cork boards. So there's a lot of cards. I recognize cards in the stories that had been on the boards.
故事情节。所以萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？这些就像极其复杂的故事情节。帕姆和安吉拉之间，德怀特和安吉拉之间，迈克尔和德怀特之间有很多好东西。这些故事带来了我们在板子上放的很多卡片。我们在前期制作中会做的一件事是，我们会为不同的故事情节、片段或B故事生成所有这些有趣的想法，它们会变成用图钉钉在软木板上的笔记卡。所以有很多卡片。我认出了故事中那些曾经在板子上的卡片。
Like I think the Mexican-themed party, for instance, was a card for Oscar and certainly the Pam and Angela relationship or Andy being more sinister and and Michael having to to wise up and realize who is who is most loyal servant was these are all fragmentary ideas that that we combined into a great episode I think a lot of moving parts Yeah, I love picturing the writer's room in these cards and them coming back around. And, Greg, I love when you send in audio clips. Thank you. I agree.
比如我认为墨西哥主题派对，例如，是奥斯卡的一张卡片，当然还有帕姆和安吉拉的关系，或者安迪变得更阴险，迈克尔不得不变得聪明起来，意识到谁是他最忠诚的仆人，这些都是我们结合成一个伟大剧集的碎片化想法，我认为有很多移动的部分。是的，我喜欢想象编剧室里的这些卡片，以及它们再次出现。而且，格雷格，我喜欢你发来音频片段的时候。谢谢。我同意。
Fast fact number three, rid-ed-d-doo. Ed Helms. You heard her, everybody. We talked to Ed Helms about this episode. This is such a big episode for Andy. He is driving most of the storyline. He is the instigator. We absolutely had to talk to Ed, so we did.
第三个速记事实，Rid-ed-d-doo。艾德·赫尔姆斯。大家都听到了。我们和艾德·赫尔姆斯谈了这一集。这对安迪来说是如此重要的一集。他推动了大部分故事情节。他是煽动者。我们绝对必须和艾德谈谈，所以我们谈了。
And it was great. It was so fun. Sam, play the interview. Streaming Tuesday on Disney Plus. Sign up today. 18 Plus subscription required TNCs apply. Ed Helms. Hello. How are you?
这太棒了。太有趣了。萨姆，播放采访。周二在Disney Plus上流媒体播放。立即注册。需18岁以上订阅，适用条款和条件。艾德·赫尔姆斯。你好。你好吗？
Hi, office ladies. Ed, it's so good to see you. You got an office guy right here in the mix. We do. We got an office fella. We got one of the best office fellas. Aw. Oh, come on.
嗨，办公室女士们。艾德，见到你真好。你这里有一个办公室家伙。我们有。我们有一个办公室家伙。我们有最好的办公室家伙之一。啊。哦，得了吧。
Well, thanks so much for being here, Ed. People just love Andy Bernard and we're so excited to talk to you about this episode. Yeah, I rewatched a little bit just so I had it in my head for this chat because I never watch it unless I happen to see it on in the background somewhere. But I love it when I catch it. Yeah. Yeah. Have you ever had that experience though where you're like flying on an airplane and you see it on all the screens that people are watching it on all their personal devices? and on the airplane, and then you're just sort of sitting there.
好吧，非常感谢你能来，艾德。人们就是喜欢安迪·伯纳德，我们非常兴奋能和你谈谈这一集。是的，我重温了一点，只是为了在这次聊天中把它记在脑子里，因为我从来不看它，除非我碰巧在背景中看到它。但我喜欢我捕捉到它的时候。是的。是的。你有没有过那种经历，比如你在飞机上飞行，你看到它在人们在他们所有个人设备上观看的所有屏幕上？在飞机上，然后你只是坐在那里。
Please don't notice me. Please don't notice me. Yeah, I'm always like, do I go to the bathroom? Do I not go to the bathroom? I was trying to time it out to go to the bathroom one time. And like, there was someone in there. So I was standing outside and I was on the little screen above my head. Oh, my God.
请不要注意到我。请不要注意到我。是的，我总是像，我去洗手间吗？我不去洗手间吗？有一次我试图计算时间去洗手间。而且，里面有人。所以我站在外面，我在我头顶的小屏幕上。天哪。
I just started to see the faces. Look at me. Look up. Look at me. Look up. And I was like, oh, God. Oh, that's amazing. Angela, I would expect you to just sit down on someone's armrest to be like,
我开始看到那些脸。看着我。向上看。看着我。向上看。我就像，哦，天哪。哦，那太棒了。安吉拉，我以为你会直接坐在某人的扶手上说，
hey, you having fun, you enjoy the episode? Well, you got any questions? I'm happy to talk about. I've exchanged more email addresses with flight attendants and made good friends on planes. Literally, I sat next to a woman one time and we're still friends to this day. We're total strangers flying to Canada. So, Ed, you watched part of the return? Yeah, yeah. I rewatched the return. You know, I watched just a couple of episodes from that first chunk of season three because that was my first time on the show. Yeah. And it feels so long ago. I can't, like, it's just not fresh in my mind, so many of those experiences. And so rewatching it, I was hoping I could kind of trigger a lot of memories of kind of the experience and the emotional memories and so forth. And it was a joy. It was really, really fun. When I watch it, I get a sense memory of my desk. I know that. I know,
嘿，你玩得开心吗，你喜欢这一集吗？好吧，你有什么问题吗？我很乐意谈谈。我和空乘人员交换了更多的电子邮件地址，并在飞机上结交了好朋友。真的，有一次我坐在一个女人旁边，我们至今仍是朋友。我们是飞往加拿大的完全陌生人。所以，艾德，你看了《回归》的一部分？是的，是的。我重温了《回归》。你知道，我只看了第三季第一部分中的几集，因为那是我第一次参加这个节目。是的。而且感觉是很久以前的事了。我不能，就像，它在我的脑海里不新鲜，那些经历中的很多。所以重温它，我希望我能触发很多关于那种经历和情感记忆等等的记忆。这是一种快乐。这真的，真的很有趣。当我观看它时，我有一种关于我的桌子的感官记忆。我知道那个。我知道，
that they've torn it down now and they do a lot of game shows where our set used to be. And I was even invited to go on one of them. And I turned it down because I didn't think that I could emotionally handle walking into the soundstage and not seeing Pam's desk. Wow. At Chandler Valley's Center Studios, they do game shows now? Yes. I did to tell the truth. And when I got the address, I said, yes, I would do it. And, you know, I don't know where things taped. So I was like, sure, I'll do it. And then I got the address, and it was Chandler Valley Studios. And I was like, what?
他们现在已经把它拆掉了，他们在我们曾经的片场做了很多游戏节目。我甚至被邀请去参加其中一个。但我拒绝了，因为我不认为我能从情感上处理走进摄影棚却看不到帕姆的桌子。哇。在钱德勒谷中心工作室，他们现在做游戏节目？是的。我说了实话。当我得到地址时，我说，是的，我会做的。而且，你知道，我不知道东西在哪里录制。所以我当时想，当然，我会做的。然后我得到了地址，那是钱德勒谷工作室。我就像，什么？
I showed up at our studio, and I started sobbing. Oh. Because it was just so weird to pull up to that building. Oh, my gosh. And there were a lot of, you know, there were, there were a lot of major chapters in our lives that went, that people went through marriages, divorces, children, all these kind of major life events that were happening. And sometimes I'll see an episode and I'll be like, oh, yeah, that's when so-and-so was going through this, or that's when that's when so-and-so child was born or, you know, and that stuff's really beautiful to
我出现在我们的工作室，我开始啜泣。哦。因为开车到那栋楼真是太奇怪了。哦，我的天哪。而且有很多，你知道，有很多我们生活中经历过的重大篇章，人们经历了婚姻、离婚、孩子，所有这些重大的生活事件都在发生。有时我会看到一集，我会想，哦，是的，那是某某正在经历这个的时候，或者那是某某孩子出生的时候，或者，你知道，那些东西真的很美，
remember. Even the, even the parts that are, that might have been painful chapters, there's still merely meaningful chapters in our lives and histories. And it's just so wild to have this show that's kind of a bookmark, right? You can just go to any point. I mean, for us, having made the show, I can recall things that I was experiencing when I see a scene or a, or I just if I catch a chunk of an episode, I can remember where I was, like in my life a little bit more. That is so true. It's really wild. And, you know, And like I said, even the ups and downs of it, it's all beautiful, right? And just to have those triggers available to remember those things, it feels very, yeah,
记住。即使是那些可能曾经是痛苦篇章的部分，它们仍然是我们生活和历史中仅仅是有意义的篇章。拥有这个节目作为一种书签真是太疯狂了，对吧？你可以去任何一点。我的意思是，对我们来说，制作了这个节目，当我看到一个场景时，我可以回忆起我正在经历的事情，或者我只是如果我捕捉到一集的一部分，我可以记得我在哪里，比如在我的生活中多一点。那太真实了。这真的很疯狂。而且，你知道，就像我说的，即使是它的起起落落，它都很美，对吧？而且仅仅拥有那些可用的触发器来记住那些事情，感觉非常，是的，
just feels very, very beautiful overall. Yeah, yeah. This, as you were saying, is such a big storyline for you, traveling salesmen leading into the return. And were you super excited to get this script to see what all you got to do and play with Steve and like you got to in this episode? Yeah, of course. I mean, it was still early enough for me.
总体感觉非常，非常美丽。是的，是的。正如你所说，这对你来说是一个如此大的故事情节，《旅行推销员》引向《回归》。你是否非常兴奋能得到这个剧本，看看你必须做的一切，并和史蒂夫一起玩，就像你在这一集中必须做的那样？是的，当然。我的意思是，对我来说还很早。
I mean, every table read is a joy, right? It's just so much discovery for the cast. The writers have been kind of in the trenches for a couple of weeks or months at that point with every episode. But for us, it's like this fresh, exciting thing. And I do I do remember feeling, you know, as I got more sort of meat on the bun, in some of those later episodes, it just felt, it really felt like an affirmation that Andy was a valuable part of this, you know, cast overall and of the show. And so, yeah, there was always a kind of giddy anticipation with those table reads. Like, oh, what am I going to get to do? What did the
我的意思是，每次剧本朗读都是一种快乐，对吧？这对演员来说只是太多的发现。编剧们在那个时候已经为每一集在战壕里待了几个星期或几个月。但对我们来说，这就像这种新鲜、令人兴奋的事情。而且我确实记得感觉，你知道，当我得到更多像面包上的肉一样的东西时，在那些后来的剧集中，它真的感觉就像一种肯定，安迪是这个，你知道，整体演员阵容和节目中宝贵的一部分。所以，是的，那些剧本朗读总是有一种轻浮的期待。就像，哦，我能做什么？编剧们想出了什么？
writers come up with? You know, and then, of course, what did the, how is Steve going to make me laugh this week. Right. Ed, this episode opens with your phone ringing, and there's like a four-part harmony of you singing. Yeah. Your ringtone. Is that you?
你知道，然后，当然，史蒂夫这周会怎么让我笑。对。艾德，这一集以你的电话铃声开始，有你唱歌的四部分和声。是的。你的铃声。那是你吗？
100% me. All four parts? All of it? Yeah. Yeah. Yep. And I did it. And just like Andy says in the show, I did it on my computer at home.
100%是我。所有四个部分？全部？是的。是的。是的。而且我做了。就像安迪在节目中所说的那样，我在家里的电脑上做的。
You, Ed, did it on Ed's computer at home. Yeah. They didn't, like, bring you into a studio or something. No, I think they, they. That tracks, actually. That does track for our show. Like, hey, can you do this whole thing at home on your flip phone or whatever we had at the time? Well, I can't remember.
你，艾德，在艾德家里的电脑上做的。是的。他们没有，比如，把你带进工作室什么的。不，我想他们，他们。这确实有迹可循，实际上。这确实符合我们的节目。比如，嘿，你能在家里用你的翻盖手机或我们当时有的任何东西做这整件事吗？好吧，我不记得了。
I think maybe, I don't think they wanted it to be very good, but I was like too into it to make it anything less. And I thought Andy would make it as good as possible, right? So I think I spent a long. time on that and garage band kind of figuring out how to do multiple tracks. But yeah, I recorded it and I sort of figured out four parts to it, which was really pretty simple. I mean, it's a very elementary kind of harmony arrangement. But it, yeah, super fun. And then I played it for Greg. And he was like, great, we'll use it. I feel like, Ed, because I know you were in an Acapella group, right, in college? Well, yeah, that's a little bit of an overblown history. I was, I was in an
我想也许，我不认为他们希望它非常好，但我当时太投入了，不能让它变得更差。而且我认为安迪会尽可能把它做得最好，对吧？所以我认为我在那个和车库乐队上花了很多时间，弄清楚如何做多个轨道。但是的，我录制了它，我算出了四个部分，这真的非常简单。我的意思是，这是一种非常基础的和声编排。但它，是的，超级有趣。然后我把它放给格雷格听。他说，太棒了，我们会用它。我觉得，艾德，因为我知道你在大学里参加过一个阿卡贝拉小组，对吧？好吧，是的，那有点夸张的历史。我曾经在，
Acapella group, but only for a semester in college. It wasn't like a huge part of my identity. Right. It was for a semester, but then I just kind of realized it wasn't for me. But, um, but you have an ear, you have an ear for music. Like, there is no way they could have given that assignment to Jen and I. Like, I know, you're like, it's a pretty easy harmony. And I'm like, is it? It is. Yeah. You're very talented. Well, since we're talking about famous Andy Bernard things, I need to ask you about riddy-d-d-do. I have the script, and I have not once ever seen it written in the script for Andy Bernard.
阿卡贝拉小组，但只是在大学里待了一个学期。它不像是我身份的很大一部分。对。它只是一个学期，但后来我意识到它不适合我。但是，嗯，但你有一只耳朵，你有一只音乐耳朵。就像，他们不可能把那个任务交给珍娜和我。就像，我知道，你就像，这是一个相当容易的和声。而我就像，是吗？它是。是的。你非常有才华。好吧，既然我们在谈论著名的安迪·伯纳德的事情，我需要问你关于“riddy-d-d-do”。我有剧本，我从来没有在安迪·伯纳德的剧本中看到过它。
You had to have invented this. I improvised a ton in my early episodes because I, again, I was eager to prove myself, and I also was trying to find Andy Bernard as a character. and that particular thing, which I think was this, I think this was the first episode where it appeared for Andy, right? Yes, yes. And so it just was this thing that these guys I went to middle school with would say they would just inject into, it was kind of like a,
你一定发明了这个。我在早期的剧集中即兴发挥了很多，因为我，再次，我渴望证明自己，而且我也在试图找到安迪·伯纳德这个角色。而那件事，我认为这是，我想这是安迪出现的第一个剧集，对吧？是的，是的。所以它只是这些家伙在中学时会说的事情，他们会把它注入到，它有点像，
there you go, gotcha, you know, if they got off like a good zing. her at your expense that they'd tag it with it. And I don't know if they weren't exactly bullies, but I just remember this little clump of guys that were sort of like wise crackers in my middle school. And I don't know where it came from before that picked it up and I always thought it was kind of a funny, obnoxious expression. It has no meaning.
给你，抓到你了，你知道，如果他们以你的代价得到了一个好的讽刺，他们会用它来标记它。而且我不知道他们是否完全是恶霸，但我只是记得那群家伙，他们在我的中学里有点像聪明人。而且我不知道它在被捡起来之前是从哪里来的，我一直认为它是一种有趣、令人讨厌的表达。它没有意义。
And it just kind of fits. in wherever you want. It's so perfect, Ed. I have such a memory of being in Scranton with you, Ed. Do you remember? I remember, like, we were there for the office convention, and there were so many people there. And you and I were in a car, and, like, there were people all around the car, and we went
而且它只是，随处可见。它太完美了，艾德。我有这样一段在斯克兰顿和你在一起的记忆，艾德。你记得吗？我记得，比如，我们在那里参加办公室大会，那里有很多人。你和我坐在一辆车里，而且，比如，车周围都是人，我们去了，
into that train shop, and we had to exit out the back. I made, that's right. We were driving through downtown Scranton, and I was like, oh, my God, it's a Lionel Train Store. We have to go in there. and I made the car stop and I made and you got out with me and we went and people started to press up against the glass and it was like Mike we were like Michael Jackson it was crazy you said to me they had they pulled the car around the back we had to like exit out the back and the man that owned the model train store he was like an elderly gentleman he had no idea who we were of what was happening he was like um I guess you can use the back door whatever and then we got in the car and you're like ang this is the closest we'll ever be to being a beetle. Like, this is our moment.
那个火车商店，我们不得不从后面出去。我做了，没错。我们开车穿过斯克兰顿市中心，我就像，哦，天哪，那是莱昂内尔火车商店。我们必须进去。我让车停下来，我让，而且你和我一起下车，我们去了，人们开始挤在玻璃上，就像迈克，我们就像迈克尔·杰克逊，这太疯狂了。你对我说，他们把车开到了后面，我们不得不从后面出去，那个拥有模型火车商店的人，他就像一位年长的绅士，他根本不知道我们是谁，发生了什么，他就像，嗯，我想你可以用后门，随便，然后我们上了车，你就像，安，这是我们最接近成为披头士的时候。就像，这是我们的时刻。
But why I bring it up is that to a crowd of people, Ed just turned to them and said, Riddit-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-U, and they lost their minds. Oh, my gosh. That's still, like, if someone is kind of trailing me in an airport, like, hey, Ed Elms, hey, Andy, Andy, what's up? I'll just toss a rid-it-da-to-do, and then they're like, And they'll leave me alone. And then they faint.
但我提起它的原因是，对一群人，艾德只是转向他们说，Riddit-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-U，他们失去了理智。哦，我的天哪。那仍然是，比如，如果有人在机场跟着我，比如，嘿，艾德·赫尔姆斯，嘿，安迪，安迪，怎么了？我只是会扔一个“rid-it-da-to-do”，然后他们就像，然后他们会让我一个人待着。然后他们晕倒了。
Well, Ed, I wanted to ask you about the scene where you punch the wall because I rewatch this with my kids. My kids are older now, Ed, and they love the office and they love Andy. And we curled up in bed and we watched this episode. And they were giggling so hard. And they wanted to know anything about it. Like, do you have any story about punching the wall? Did you really do it? What was it like?
好吧，艾德，我想问你关于你打墙的那个场景，因为我和我的孩子们重温了这一集。我的孩子们现在长大了，艾德，他们喜欢《办公室》，他们喜欢安迪。我们蜷缩在床上，看了这一集。他们咯咯地笑得太厉害了。他们想知道关于它的任何事情。比如，你有什么关于打墙的故事吗？你真的做了吗？那是什么感觉？
I know Jenna had a front row seat at reception. Yeah. Accounting watched it from afar. Well, it's funny because that was technically a stunt, right? And in like a production, from a production standpoint, the sort of stunt affects people have to oversee something like that. And so I remember it was my first time doing anything that qualified as a stunt. So like there was a whole little meeting about how they were going to score the back of the sheet. so that my hand went through easier and then they were going to put up they like fixed a pad onto
我知道珍娜在接待处有前排座位。是的。会计部从远处看着它。好吧，这很有趣，因为那在技术上是一个特技，对吧？而且在比如制作中，从制作的角度来看，那种特技效果的人必须监督这样的事情。所以我记得那是我第一次做任何有资格作为特技的事情。所以，比如有一个关于他们将如何给板材背面刻痕的小会议，这样我的手更容易穿过去，然后他们要放上去，他们固定了一个垫子在，
the inner wall so that when my hand went through um i wouldn't hit you know wood or aluminum or anything and also they had multiple planks that they could stick up just so we could do multiple takes um but it's still i mean you guys know anytime you as a character are holding court in for the whole bullpen, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's daunting, right? It's, it's, it's, it's kind of something that, that, uh, I think was, I always felt anxious about in a good way, like in a kind of, um, you know, I was always amped up for those kinds of things. It's also what makes me just stay in awe of Correll because so many of his scenes were with the entire cast where he's like running a scene with the entire cast. And that's so hard. I mean, that is just, it is a really, it takes a
内墙上，这样当我的手穿过去时，嗯，我就不会撞到，你知道，木头或铝或任何东西，而且他们还有多个木板，他们可以贴上去，这样我们就可以进行多次拍摄，但这仍然，我的意思是你们知道任何时候你作为一个角色在整个牛棚里主持法庭，这，这，这，这，这，这令人望而生畏，对吧？这，这，这，这，这有点事情，那，呃，我想是，我总是对那些事情感到焦虑，以一种好的方式，比如以一种，嗯，你知道，我总是对那种事情感到兴奋。这也是让我对卡雷尔保持敬畏的原因，因为他的许多场景都是和整个演员阵容一起的，在那里他就像和整个演员阵容一起运行一个场景。而且这太难了。我的意思是，那只是，它确实需要一个，
tremendous amount of focus and concentration because everyone's lines are responding off of yours as opposed to. And so you have to drive the scene as opposed to being someone who's just responding to somebody else who's, which is what we all got to do with Steve. So that, that was one of those scenes for me and a very early one and something that I think was very exciting but also kind of daunting. And I really didn't want to screw up the punch. I didn't want to get it wrong or there were a lot of kind of windups to practice swings, if you will.
巨大的专注和集中力，因为每个人的台词都是在回应你的，而不是。所以你必须推动场景，而不是成为一个只是回应别人的人，这正是我们所有人必须和史蒂夫一起做的。所以那，那对我来说是那些场景之一，而且是一个非常早期的场景，而且我认为非常令人兴奋，但也令人望而生畏。而且我真的不想搞砸那一拳。我不想弄错，或者有许多种练习挥杆的预备动作，如果你愿意的话。
And then I think we only did two takes or so. And I skinned up my knuckles. I do remember, you know, I got to, I still, there was a pad in there, but I still, I think, breaking through the sheet rock, skinned up my knuckles. So, yeah, that was pretty intense. I remember you shed some blood for that one. Yeah, I remember that. But I also remember feeling as a person who was in the bullpen watching how I could not break.
然后我想我们只拍了两次左右。而且我擦伤了我的指关节。我确实记得，你知道，我不得不，我仍然，里面有一个垫子，但我仍然，我想，打破干墙，擦伤了我的指关节。所以，是的，那相当激烈。我记得你为那个流了一些血。是的，我记得那个。但我还记得作为一个在牛棚里看着的人，我怎么能不崩溃。
Because I knew the pressure you were under. And I also knew we didn't have that many of the walls. They had extra, but it's not like they had 14. So we couldn't crack up when you punched the wall. We had to hold ourselves together. So I remember it being like, oh boy, all right, bite the inside of your lip. Whatever you have to do, do not mess. mess this up.
因为我知道你承受的压力。而且我也知道我们没有那么多墙。他们有额外的，但并不是说他们有14个。所以当你打墙时我们不能笑出来。我们必须保持冷静。所以我记得它就像，哦，男孩，好吧，咬住你的嘴唇内侧。无论你必须做什么，不要搞砸。
Oh my gosh. There's so many of those moments of trying to not look at what's happening because it's too funny. Yeah. I can just remember like. I feel like that was most of our day. If I were in the bullpen for a scene like that and didn't want to laugh, I would just be looking at the wall three feet to the right, just because that was my trick.
搞砸这个。哦，我的天哪。有太多那些试图不看正在发生的事情的时刻，因为它太搞笑了。是的。我只是记得像。我觉得那是我一天中的大部分时间。如果我在牛棚里拍那样的场景，不想笑，我只会看着右边三英尺处的墙，只是因为那是我的诀窍。
I always just looked somewhere else because everyone, everyone. and everyone's just so damn funny. I used to look at Steve's neck. I know that's so weird. Yeah. I looked at his ear a lot. But I love that you were looking at his ear. I was looking at his neck.
我总是只是看别处，因为每个人，每个人。而且每个人的都太该死的好笑了。我过去常看史蒂夫的脖子。我知道那太奇怪了。是的。我看了很多他的耳朵。但我喜欢你看着他的耳朵。我看着他的脖子。
Yeah. I would usually look at like his forehead. These are the parts of Steve. Yeah. I can tell you all about his ear. Yeah. Steve right now is like, oh, good Lord. There's something like so much of his of Michael Scott was in those eyes.
是的。我通常会看像他的前额。这些是史蒂夫的部分。是的。我可以告诉你所有关于他的耳朵。是的。史蒂夫现在就像，哦，好上帝。有某种东西，迈克尔·斯科特的很多东西都在那些眼睛里。
And if you locked in on him, you're done. done. Just like all of the tsunami of comedy that is Michael Scott would just like wash over you. And I could almost never keep it together with him. Even just the dumbest little moments. He just. Well, you guys had so many great moments in this episode. Like I love when you're in his office, like telling him about like, I'm going to get my beer on, get my lost on. And you follow him to the bathroom. Yeah. What was that like? I'm on my way to the kitchen. I'll follow you. I'll walk you there. Yeah. Oh, God.
如果你锁定他，你就完了。完了。就像迈克尔·斯科特的所有喜剧海啸会像那样冲刷你。而且我几乎从来不能和他保持冷静。即使只是最愚蠢的小时刻。他只是。好吧，你们在这一集中有很多伟大的时刻。比如我喜欢当你在他的办公室里，比如，告诉他关于，我要去喝我的啤酒，去迷失。而且你跟着他去洗手间。是的。那是什么感觉？我在去厨房的路上。我跟着你。我陪你走过去。是的。哦，上帝。
Yeah. So, I mean, the writers just, you know, there was something, a few of the writers, and Mike Scher in particular, we really bonded at that time because for some reason, Mike Schur just got Andy Bernard in this really weird way. I mean, maybe there's some bit of Andy Bernard in Michael Scher, as well. well. But I mean, the stuff they came up with for him, I would read these scripts or, you know, be at the table read and I'd be like, yes, this is exactly what Andy would do. This is exactly how the Andy in my head, the way that I think about him would behave. And so I just got it. I felt
是的。所以，我的意思是，编剧们只是，你知道，有一些东西，几个编剧，特别是迈克·谢尔，我们在那个时候真的建立了联系，因为出于某种原因，迈克·舒尔以这种非常奇怪的方式理解安迪·伯纳德。我的意思是，也许迈克尔·舒尔身上也有安迪·伯纳德的一点点。嗯。但我的意思是，他们为他想出的东西，我会读这些剧本，或者，你知道，在剧本朗读会上，我会想，是的，这正是安迪会做的。这正是安迪在我脑海中的样子，我思考他的方式会表现出来的。所以我只是明白了。我感觉，
like these scenes were like such a perfect fit, like putting on a nice comfy sweater. I mean, you guys know the writers paid such close attention to the actors that so that they've and it's that great thing that happens around late in season two or season three of a show or even early earlier than that where the writers start to write towards the strengths of the actors or towards certain personality traits or mannerisms or all just these incredibly specific things that start to bubble up um and uh and mike sure and i would just sit around and laugh and like come up with bits about who and he was and his background and his family life and and just die laughing and we just had we just had such a common understanding of of the character that things like that
这些场景就像如此完美的契合，就像穿上一件舒适的毛衣。我的意思是，你们知道编剧们对演员们给予了如此密切的关注，以至于他们已经，而且这是在节目第三季后期或甚至更早的时候发生的伟大的事情，编剧们开始朝着演员的优势或朝着某些个性特征或举止或所有这些开始冒出来的极其具体的事情写作，而且，呃，而且迈克·舒尔和我只是坐在一起笑，比如想出关于安迪是谁以及他的背景和家庭生活的片段，而且只是笑死，我们只是对这个角色有如此共同的理解，以至于像那样的事情，
walking michael to the bathroom which is so insane but it made perfect sense to me for Andy and was just a joy to do. Well, I can tell you, Ed, that the cast, when we got to see you be in scenes, when you finally came, you know, because we didn't see you guys. You guys were over at Stanford, and we didn't get to interact with you.
陪迈克尔去洗手间，这太疯狂了，但对我来说，安迪完全说得通，而且做起来是一种快乐。好吧，我可以告诉你，艾德，演员们，当我们看到你在场景中时，当你最终来的时候，你知道，因为我们没有看到你们。你们在斯坦福，我们没有机会和你们互动。
And when we finally got to see you in scenes, you just crushed every scene you were in, and you were so funny. And I remember trying so hard not to laugh. It used to be my goal, don't laugh when Steve does something. Don't laugh when Steve does something. And then all of a sudden I had to add this other layer of like, now don't laugh when to add to something.
当我们最终看到你们在场景中时，你只是粉碎了你所在的每一个场景，而且你太搞笑了。而且我记得非常努力地不笑。这曾经是我的目标，当史蒂夫做某事时不要笑。当史蒂夫做某事时不要笑。然后突然我不得不增加这一层，比如，现在当安迪做某事时不要笑。
Oh, my God. Oh, that's so sweet. I remember laughing with you, Angela, so hard about the Michael's trying to play a jukebox, but he can't start the tune. So Andy starts doing the Night at the Roxbury song. Yes. That is in, is that in the merger? Yeah, I think so. I think.
哦，我的天哪。哦，那太甜了。我记得和你，安吉拉，一起笑得那么厉害，关于迈克尔试图播放点唱机，但他不能开始曲调。所以安迪开始做《罗克斯伯里之夜》的歌。是的。那是在，那是在合并中吗？是的，我想是。我想。
Peep-pom, peep-pon, peep-pon. And we would do, you and I would just do that for hours and just crack each other up. What is love? Our trailers were side by side. So you were the one, you know, I just walked out my door and went around the corner and there you were. And I know I have this memory of walking past your trailer because you would have the door open. You'd be playing your band door or something. And I would walk past your door and go, peepo, paw, paw, peepo, peepo.
Peep-pom, peep-pon, peep-pon。而且我们会做，你和我只是会做那个几个小时，只是让对方笑。什么是爱？我们的拖车是并排的。所以你是那个，你知道，我只是走出我的门，绕过拐角，你就坐在那里。而且我知道我有这段走过你拖车的记忆，因为你会把门打开。你会弹你的班卓琴什么的。而且我会走过你的门，说，peepo, paw, paw, peepo, peepo。
Oh my gosh. Well, I loved the addition of Andy because you were this great foil to Dwight. Like, Jim would always tease Dwight or prank Dwight. You had this, like, power struggle with Dwight that was so funny to me. And in rewatching it, I just love every time you and Rain would face off. And there must have been so much improv in that because I feel like now having the scripts when I go back and look, I can see now percentage-wise how much more of different people's improvs make it in the show. And I have to say that you and Rain Wilson have the highest amount of improv that makes the cut.
哦，我的天哪。好吧，我喜欢安迪的加入，因为你是德怀特的这个伟大的陪衬。比如，吉姆总是会戏弄德怀特或恶作剧德怀特。你有一种，比如，和德怀特的权力斗争，这对我来说太搞笑了。而且在重温它时，我只是喜欢每次你和雷恩面对面的时候。而且那一定有很多即兴表演，因为我觉得现在有了剧本，当我回去看时，我现在可以看到百分比上，有多少不同人的即兴表演进入了节目。而且我不得不说，你和雷恩·威尔逊有最高数量的即兴表演进入了剪辑。
Wow. That's cool. Well, until Zach Woods joins the cast and then Zach Woods just demolished the improv. He is a genius. And he's so smart. So, so smart and funny. Yeah. But yeah, Jenna, it's fun.
哇。那很酷。好吧，直到扎克·伍兹加入演员阵容，然后扎克·伍兹只是拆毁了即兴表演。他是一个天才。而且他太聪明了。所以，非常聪明和有趣。是的。但是的，珍娜，这很有趣。
You're right. I think the Jim Dwight dynamic was hilarious because Jim was a reasonable person and Dwight is a sort of whacked out unreasonable person. And seeing Jim always in a sort of superior role just messing with Dwight was fun and gratifying to see. you know, Andy was also whacked out. And so he really was at Dwight's level. And that, I think, made their conflict super fun and certainly super fun for Rain and me. I just can, yeah, so many, so many hard laughs with that guy. And you guys would compete over the stupidest things.
你是对的。我认为吉姆和德怀特的动态太搞笑了，因为吉姆是一个理智的人，而德怀特是一个有点疯狂的不理智的人。而且看到吉姆总是处于一种优越的角色，只是戏弄德怀特，这很有趣，而且看到它很令人满足。你知道，安迪也疯了。所以他确实处于德怀特的水平。而且那，我认为，使他们的冲突超级有趣，当然对雷恩和我来说超级有趣。我只是可以，是的，和那个家伙有很多，很多大笑。而且你们会为了最愚蠢的事情竞争。
I mean, I know it's not in this episode, but there's a deleted scene where you two like are going head to head about who was the better baby? Like, you're in the kitchen, and you're like, well, I was a beautiful baby. I was a model. So I was a model baby. I modeled. And then he's like, well, I was so big. My mom couldn't walk.
我的意思是，我知道这一集里没有，但有一个被删减的片段，你们两个在争论谁是更好的婴儿？就像，你们在厨房里，你说，嗯，我是一个漂亮的婴儿。我是一个模特。所以我是一个模特婴儿。我当过模特。然后他说，嗯，我太大了。我妈妈都走不动路了。
And you're like, gross. But it's like this crazy competition over the stupidest thing. Yeah, but you're competing over who was the better baby, but your standards for what better baby means aren't even the same. Like you're not arguing over who was most beautiful or who was largest. It's like this complicated one-upmanship. and I love it. Oh, so such flawed characters.
然后你说，真恶心。但这就像是为了最愚蠢的事情而进行的疯狂竞争。是的，但你们在争论谁是更好的婴儿，但你们对“更好的婴儿”的标准甚至都不一样。就像你们不是在争论谁最漂亮或谁最大。这就像是一种复杂的攀比。我喜欢这个。哦，真是太有缺陷的角色了。
Deliciously flawed. And I think, you know, the pettiness of Andy was a bit cathartic for me because, you know, it just, it was a way, it was a way, I was saying we all have petty reactions and impulses and thoughts about going through life. But in Andy, I was able to just fully act out all of them. Lean into it. Yeah, like whatever petty impulses or instincts bubbled up, it just, I was able to kind of funnel through Andy. I love that. I love that, Ed, because I have to say, when I think of you, I would consider you one of the least petty people. I mean, I can't even, I don't even have a memory of you griping.
令人愉悦的缺陷。我想，你知道，安迪的这种小气对我来说有点宣泄作用，因为，你知道，这只是一种方式，我是在说我们每个人在生活中都会有小气的反应、冲动和想法。但在安迪身上，我可以完全把它们表现出来。顺其自然。是的，无论冒出什么小气的冲动或本能，我都能通过安迪发泄出来。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个，埃德，因为我必须说，当我想到你时，我会认为你是最不小气的人之一。我的意思是，我甚至，我甚至不记得你有过抱怨。
I always found you to be such a role model in that way, too, because that's fun. You got to let it all hang out with Andy then. Well, yeah, maybe I would have been a much more unstable person if I didn't get to play handy, if I didn't have that release valve. He balanced you out. Yeah. But I really can't overstate, you know, just my gratitude to all of you guys for when we started in Stanford just that feeling of welcome. And it was you guys, but also all the writers. And then when we arrived at Scranton, that was, it was very scary and daunting.
我一直觉得你在这方面也是一个很好的榜样，因为那很有趣。那你就可以在安迪身上尽情释放了。嗯，是的，也许如果我没有机会扮演安迪，如果我没有那个释放阀，我会是一个更不稳定的人。他平衡了你。是的。但我真的无法夸大，你知道，我对你们所有人在我们刚开始在斯坦福时给予的欢迎感到多么感激。是你们，还有所有的编剧。然后当我们到达斯克兰顿时，那是非常可怕和令人生畏的。
But we never, I just, we never felt like there was any threat. We never felt like there was anything we had to, anything personal we had to overcome to prove ourselves to you guys. It just felt like you guys were happy to have us. And that's the most incredible, the most incredible environment to be creative in. We really, Ed, someday want you in creed to just play the banjo and mandolin like you did on set. I don't know where this fits in an office ladies podcast, but someday we want you here and to hear that. Any time. Yay. Anytime. This has been so fun. And, yeah, it's just really fun to get into this headspace with you guys.
但我们从来，我只是，我们从来没有感到任何威胁。我们从来没有觉得有什么我们需要克服的个人问题来向你们证明自己。只是觉得你们很高兴有我们加入。那是进行创作的最不可思议、最不可思议的环境。埃德，我们真的希望有一天你能和克里德一起弹奏班卓琴和曼陀林，就像你在片场做的那样。我不知道这在《办公室》播客里怎么合适，但有一天我们希望你来这里，听听那个。随时都可以。耶。随时都可以。这太有趣了。而且，是的，能和你们一起进入这种心境真的很有趣。
So thanks for that. Well, before we go, I want to hear a little bit about the new show that you're doing with Mike Scher. Oh, yeah. A peacock called Rutherford Falls. Yeah. Ever since the office, obviously, Mike has gone on to do these just incredible shows. But we've stayed close friends. And so we just came up with this character, Nathan Rutherford, who lives in the small
所以谢谢你。嗯，在我们走之前，我想听听你和迈克·舒尔正在做的新剧。哦，是的。在孔雀台播出的《卢瑟福瀑布》。是的。自从《办公室》之后，显然，迈克继续制作了这些令人难以置信的剧集。但我们一直保持着亲密的朋友关系。所以我们想出了这个角色，内森·卢瑟福，他住在一个小镇。
town of Rutherford Falls in upstate New York. And he is the curator of the local museum about Rutherford Falls. And he's a descendant of the town founder, Lawrence Rutherford. So he's incredibly enthusiastic about Rutherford Falls and all of its history. And he also has his best friend, Regan, who is Native American and grew up on the reservation next to the town in upstate New York. And so the two of them, and she also runs a cultural center there on her reservation, but it just felt important to kind of address some of the reasons why people believe what they believe and why it can be so hard to accept a different version of your own kind of personal narrative, even when you're confronted with like, overworked.
位于纽约州北部的卢瑟福瀑布镇。他是当地卢瑟福瀑布博物馆的馆长。他是镇创始人劳伦斯·卢瑟福的后裔。所以他对卢瑟福瀑布及其所有历史都非常热情。他还有他最好的朋友里根，她是美洲原住民，在纽约州北部小镇旁边的保留地长大。所以他们两个，她也在她的保留地经营着一个文化中心，但这感觉很重要，去探讨人们为什么相信他们所相信的东西，以及为什么接受自己个人叙事的不同版本会如此困难，即使当你面对像过度工作一样的东西时。
overwhelming evidence that maybe you're wrong about what you thought about your history or your town or whatever. And so that's really the crux of the show is this friendship kind of being challenged. And it also is super, super funny. It sounds very heavy what I'm saying, what I'm describing. And it does have some heavy themes, but it's super, super, super funny. We roped in also very early on as our showrunner, Sierra Teller Ornellis. I worked with her on splitting up together. Hey, there you go. Yeah.
压倒性的证据表明，也许你对你的历史或你的城镇或其他什么的看法是错误的。所以这确实是这部剧的核心，这种友谊受到了挑战。而且它也超级超级有趣。我所描述的听起来很沉重。它确实有一些沉重的主题，但它超级超级超级有趣。我们很早就把我们的剧集主管塞拉·泰勒·奥内利斯拉了进来。我和她在《分居在一起》中合作过。嘿，这就对了。是的。
Yeah. So she's our showrunner and she's just incredible. And then she just put together this incredible writing staff. And we've been cranking on it. Well, but we were supposed to start shooting right when the lockdown started. And now we're just. kind of trying to figure it out. Well, I can't wait until you guys can start filming and we can start watching that because it sounds so great.
是的。所以她是我们的剧集主管，她简直太不可思议了。然后她组建了这个令人难以置信的编剧团队。我们一直在努力工作。嗯，但我们本应在封锁开始时就开始拍摄。现在我们只是。试图弄清楚。嗯，我迫不及待地想等你们开始拍摄，我们就可以开始看了，因为它听起来太棒了。
Before you go, is there anything else you want to share, any memories from the show? We don't want to leave you if you have anything else to say, but also no pressure. It just is something I cherish so much having been a part of that. And the friendships that have endured, I mean, I can't believe we're all still on a text chain. I know. That blows my mind. And I just, I love that so much. And I love the, just a little blurp from Oscar and then Creed will chime in and
在你走之前，还有什么你想分享的吗，关于这部剧的任何回忆？如果你还有什么想说的，我们不想让你离开，但也别有压力。这只是我非常珍惜的事情，能成为其中的一部分。以及那些持久的友谊，我的意思是，我不敢相信我们还在一个短信群里。我知道。这让我很震惊。我只是，我非常喜欢这一点。我喜欢，只是奥斯卡的一点小消息，然后克里德会插话，然后。
everybody just, and sometimes they're funny and sometimes they're, they're just like information or news or whatever. But it's, it just, I don't know, it speaks to. I think that is what made, that's why the show has endured the way it has is. because the camaraderie was real. Yeah. You know, the friendships and the kind of mutual love and support and respect was real on that set. And even though the characters were in, like, ridiculous conflict all the time, there was always, I think people could pick up on an underlying sense that, that Dunder Mifflin kind of had a foundation of love.
每个人都只是，有时他们很有趣，有时他们只是像信息或新闻什么的。但是，它，我不知道，它说明了。我认为这就是让，这就是为什么这部剧能像现在这样持久的原因。因为那种情谊是真实的。是的。你知道，那种友谊以及那种相互的爱、支持和尊重在那个片场是真实的。尽管角色们一直处于荒谬的冲突中，但我认为人们总是能感受到一种潜在的感觉，即邓德·米夫林有一种爱的基础。
Yeah. Does that make sense? Ed, yes. I love that. Well, Ed, thank you so, so very much for coming on and talking to us and sharing your stories. It's just been wonderful. And we'll bug you down the line because I have a good dinner party story with you. You can't tell that story.
是的。这有道理吗？埃德，是的。我喜欢这个。好吧，埃德，非常非常感谢你来和我们交谈并分享你的故事。这真是太棒了。以后我们会烦你的，因为我有一个关于你的很好的晚宴故事。你不能讲那个故事。
No, you have to talk about it. I'm not telling, wait, I'm not even talking about that one. I know what you're talking about in the car. I'm just talking about I have a dinner party moment, but we'll get there. Okay. I can't wait to come back, guys. You're the best. Love you, Ed.
不，你必须谈谈它。我不是在讲，等等，我甚至不是在说那个。我知道你在车里说的是什么。我只是说我有一个晚宴时刻，但我们会讲到的。好的。我迫不及待想再来，伙计们。你们是最棒的。爱你，埃德。
Any time. All right. Thanks, Ed. Searchlight Pictures presents, The Roses, only in theaters, August 29th. From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things comes The Roses, starring Academy Award winner, Olivia Col. Academy Award nominee Benedict Cumberbatch, Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Alison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses.
随时都可以。好的。谢谢，埃德。探照灯影业呈现，《玫瑰》，8月29日仅在影院上映。来自《拜见岳父大人》的导演和《可怜的东西》的编剧，带来了《玫瑰》，由奥斯卡奖得主奥利维亚·科尔曼主演。奥斯卡奖提名者本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇、安迪·萨姆伯格、凯特·麦金农和艾莉森·珍妮。一部充满戏剧性、兴奋和一点点仇恨的搞笑新喜剧，证明了婚姻并不总是一床玫瑰花。
See The Roses only in theaters, August 29th. All right, well, we are back. Jenna, let's get into this episode. Yeah, so guys, Dwight has left Dunder Mifflin, and he's on the job. job market. So this episode opens with Dwight going on some job interviews. We see him interviewed by two different people, a man and a woman. And our fun cameo catch tidbit is that the man who interviews Dwight at the beginning of this episode is Kevin Riley. Kevin Riley, who was the president of NBC. You guys have heard us talk about him. He is the reason the office stayed on the air. He
8月29日仅在影院观看《玫瑰》。好的，好吧，我们回来了。珍娜，让我们进入这一集。是的，所以伙计们，德怀特离开了邓德·米夫林，他正在就业市场上。所以这一集以德怀特去参加一些工作面试开始。我们看到他被两个人面试，一个男人和一个女人。我们有趣的客串花絮是，在这一集开头面试德怀特的男人是凯文·赖利。凯文·赖利，他是NBC的总裁。你们听我们谈论过他。他是《办公室》能继续播出的原因。他。
fought so hard for us. So this was really fun and special to have him sort of pop in and make it into an episode. Yeah, I asked Greg about this and he said he got the idea because Greg's father had worked as a radio executive and he was really funny and smart like Kevin, he said. And when he left ABC, they gave him a present that he could appear as a magician in one of their soap operas. Oh, my God. So he thought this would be a really. fun way, especially with the office being documentary style to cast a real person, a real executive instead of an actor. And also, this would kind of commemorate Kevin Riley's contribution to our show staying on the air. Oh, well, then Dwight goes on to his second interview
为我们奋斗得如此努力。所以能让他客串并出现在一集中真的很有趣也很特别。是的，我问过格雷格这件事，他说他有了这个想法，因为格雷格的父亲曾担任广播主管，他像凯文一样非常有趣和聪明，他说。当他离开ABC时，他们给了他一份礼物，让他可以在他们的一部肥皂剧中扮演魔术师。哦，我的天哪。所以他认为这会是一个非常有趣的方式，特别是《办公室》是纪录片风格，去选一个真实的人，一个真正的高管而不是演员。而且，这也将纪念凯文·赖利对我们剧集继续播出的贡献。哦，好吧，然后德怀特去参加了他的第二次面试。
and it's a woman, right? Yes. Clearly, you know, we're picking up in the middle of the interview, she must have said to him to describe himself with three words. Dwight says he's hardworking, alpha male, jackhammer, merciless, insatiable. And as he's saying this, if you look around the office, it is the most feminine pink office you will ever see. Everything in it is pink. Every container on her desk, the paint on the wall is pink. The flower behind her is a whole bunch of pink flowers. And Dwight is throwing out alpha male and it's like merciless. And you can just sort of see her being like, Hmm. Well, it's very interesting because I noted this as well. I noticed there's a fuzzy purple butterfly frame on the desk and like a tassel lamp that has fireflies on it. So I got a little curious about this. Like, what's the story behind this? Did a 12-year-old girl decorate this office? Well, I guess in the script, Mike Schur had named this character Gwendolyn Trundlebed.
是一个女人，对吧？是的。显然，你知道，我们在面试中途切入，她一定让他用三个词来描述自己。德怀特说他是一个勤奋的、阿尔法男性的、冲击钻、无情的、贪得无厌的。当他说这些话时，如果你环顾办公室，那是你见过的最女性化的粉红色办公室。里面的一切都是粉红色的。她桌上的每一个容器，墙上的油漆都是粉红色的。她身后的花是一大束粉红色的花。而德怀特正在抛出“阿尔法男性”，这就像“无情的”。你可以看出她好像在说，嗯。好吧，这非常有趣，因为我也注意到了这一点。我注意到桌子上有一个模糊的紫色蝴蝶框，还有一个有萤火虫的流苏灯。所以我对这个有点好奇。这是怎么回事？是一个12岁的小女孩装饰了这个办公室吗？好吧，我想在剧本里，迈克·舒尔给这个角色取名为格温多琳·特伦德贝德。
Oh, my lord. This is bringing up some Clementine Paddleford memories for me, Angela. Yes. A hundred percent Clementine Paddleford and Gwendolyn Trundelbet are friends in a Disney film. But this woman, we never call her by name. She was played by a background performer. She didn't have any lines. But I guess the set decorators, they really took it to heart.
哦，我的天哪。这让我想起了一些克莱门汀·帕德尔福德的回忆，安吉拉。是的。百分之百，克莱门汀·帕德尔福德和格温多琳·特伦德贝德是迪士尼电影里的朋友。但这个女人，我们从来没有叫过她的名字。她是由一个背景演员扮演的。她没有任何台词。但我猜布景师，他们真的把它放在心上了。
And they were inspired by the name Gwendolyn Trundelbed. and that is why the office looks the way it does. Well, it works perfectly because Dwight, I feel like is coming in there with all this sort of like macho energy and he came into Gwendolyn Trundlebed's boudoir of pinkness. That's what it looks like. It's very boudoir looking. Eventually, we find out that Dwight lands at Staples.
他们受到了格温多琳·特伦德贝德这个名字的启发，这就是为什么办公室看起来是那个样子的。好吧，这很完美，因为德怀特，我觉得他带着那种大男子主义的能量进去了，他走进了格温多琳·特伦德贝德的粉红色闺房。看起来就是那样。看起来非常像闺房。最终，我们发现德怀特在史泰博落脚了。
He says it's temporary while he continues his job search. Remember, Staples is Dunder Mifflin's big competitor. They're their big rival. I know. Yeah. But then back at the office, Andy has taken Dwight's seat across from Jim. Yeah. Yeah.
他说这只是暂时的，同时他继续寻找工作。记住，史泰博是邓德·米夫林的竞争对手。他们是他们最大的竞争对手。我知道。是的。但回到办公室，安迪已经坐到了德怀特在吉姆对面的位置。是的。是的。
And he's really proud of the ringtone. We talked about it with Ed, but he is very proud that he did all four parts of the harmony. And I don't know music, Jenna. I don't even know what you call it. I have to tell you, I still, I know we talked about this with Ed, but it's still, it's incredibly impressive. I mean, it's so impressive. It really, I mean, Acapella is really impressive. Aco-what?
他真的很为那个铃声感到自豪。我们和埃德谈过，但他非常自豪他完成了和声的所有四个部分。我不懂音乐，珍娜。我甚至不知道你怎么称呼它。我必须告诉你，我仍然，我知道我们和埃德谈过这个，但这仍然，令人难以置信地印象深刻。我的意思是，这太令人印象深刻了。真的，我的意思是，阿卡贝拉真的令人印象深刻。阿卡什么？
Yeah, I just said it, because there's one guy that's like, bing, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, you know what I mean? Yeah. And then there's another person that's like, la, la, like, I don't get it. But it sounded amazing. I still can't believe he did that himself. One of the things I love about the scene, obviously, how much Andy's annoying everyone already. But he calls Ryan big turkey. Yeah.
是的，我刚才说了，因为有一个人就像，叮，蹦，蹦，蹦，蹦，蹦，你知道我的意思吗？是的。然后还有另一个人就像，啦，啦，就像，我不明白。但听起来很棒。我仍然不敢相信他自己做了那个。我喜欢这个场景的一点是，显然，安迪已经让每个人都很烦了。但他叫瑞安“大火鸡”。是的。
Does that mean that Ryan eats turkey sandwiches for lunch? It has to. It has to. What are we learning here? Well, clearly, I mean, Andy had a friend called Broccoli Rob. Do you know what I mean? Yes. All of the nicknames are just what you eat?
那是不是意味着瑞安午餐吃火鸡三明治？一定是。一定是。我们在这里学到了什么？好吧，显然，我的意思是，安迪有一个叫“西兰花罗布”的朋友。你知道我的意思吗？是的。所有的绰号都只是你吃的东西吗？
Yeah, I'm Yogurt Pam. I'd be Donut Kinsey. Well, in real life. Oh, in real life, yes. I guess I'd be eggs and strawberries fisher. That's catchy. Jenna, I feel like there is a very classic Jim Pam shot that we have to talk about. What is it?
是的，我是“酸奶帕姆”。我会是“甜甜圈金赛”。好吧，在现实生活中。哦，在现实生活中，是的。我想我会是“鸡蛋和草莓费舍尔”。那很顺口。珍娜，我觉得有一个非常经典的吉姆和帕姆的镜头，我们必须谈谈。是什么？
It's at one minute, 58 seconds. Andy is singing the ridiculous version of Andy and the tuna, you know, that whole part? Yes, yes. And the camera focuses on Jim's reaction and then pushes past Jim and Jim goes out of focus and it lands on Pam. And they both have similar expressions of like, oh, my God, this guy. And for me, I don't know. I know I love Jim and Pam so much. So I don't know if I'm like looking for.
在1分58秒。安迪正在唱那个荒谬版本的《安迪和金枪鱼》，你知道，那整部分？是的，是的。摄像机聚焦在吉姆的反应上，然后推过吉姆，吉姆失焦了，落在了帕姆身上。他们都有相似的表情，就像，哦，我的天，这家伙。对我来说，我不知道。我知道我非常爱吉姆和帕姆。所以我不知道我是不是在寻找。
for meaning. But in that moment, I'm like, they're on the same page. These two are both in it. Like, they're going to be in it together for this episode because it's hitting them the same way. Yes. I think this is that first hint that they are in sync. I think so. And it was just also a beautiful shot just to be a technical nerd. Like, that is a beautiful shot. I agree. Well, now Michael arrives to work, and he's parked his car. His, you know what? His roof won't go up, but who cares? It's fine. He's going to leave it. Nope, it's not going to be a problem. It's not going to be a big deal on the biggest snow day they've had. I watched this episode with my kids. I know I talked about that. They loved his hair. They loved how his hair was just messy from getting out of his car.
意义。但在那一刻，我想，他们想的一样。这两个人都在其中。就像，他们这一集要一起经历这个，因为它对他们的影响是一样的。是的。我认为这是他们同步的第一个暗示。我想是这样。而且作为一个技术宅，这也是一个美丽的镜头。就像，那是一个美丽的镜头。我同意。好吧，现在迈克尔来上班了，他停好了车。他的，你知道吗？他的车顶打不开，但谁在乎呢？没关系。他要把它留在那里。不，这不是问题。在他们经历过的最大的雪天里，这不会是什么大不了的事。我和我的孩子们一起看了这一集。我知道我谈过那个。他们喜欢他的头发。他们喜欢他的头发因为下车而变得凌乱的样子。
I didn't even notice that. That's such a good detail. I know. I know. They catch a few things. I'm going to sprinkle them through. I love that. Well, Oscar arrives, next to Michael and he is welcomed back by Michael. Yeah, Michael says, hey, nice new car. And Oscar said, well, I got this new car in the settlement after you kissed me at work. I love how matter of factly, Oscar says it. That Lexus SUV, that's all you, buddy. And then Michael's like, well, that's how we do it here, Dunder Mifflin. When we settle, we settle high. So. And then Oscar has that great talking head where he says, part of him wants people in the office to have learned their lesson and to shut the hell up. But another part of him wants them to keep talking so he can
我甚至没注意到。那是一个很好的细节。我知道。我知道。他们捕捉到了一些东西。我会把它们点缀在里面。我喜欢这个。好吧，奥斯卡到了，在迈克尔旁边，他受到了迈克尔的欢迎。是的，迈克尔说，嘿，新车不错。奥斯卡说，嗯，我在你吻我之后得到的和解金里买了这辆新车。我喜欢奥斯卡说得那么理所当然。那辆雷克萨斯SUV，那全是你的功劳，伙计。然后迈克尔说，嗯，这就是我们在邓德·米夫林做事的方式。当我们和解时，我们和解得很高。所以。然后奥斯卡有那个很棒的谈话头，他说，他的一部分希望办公室里的人能吸取教训，闭上该死的嘴。但另一部分希望他们继续说，这样他就可以。
buy a home theater. So now we go into Michael's office. And Jenna, it's one of those classic scenes that you and I love where it starts with Michael and who else is in the room. You don't know. And then it's revealed. And this time it's Andy. Andy is taking the spot of Dwight over Michael's shoulder. But he's creeping Michael out. You can already tell. Well, there's a way that Michael is always kind of annoyed when Dwight interjects in the middle of what Michael is saying, but this is different. Like, Michael's annoyed by Dwight, but Michael, like, really is annoyed by Andy. Well, you know what it feels like to me, like Andy is getting under his skin.
买一个家庭影院。所以现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室。珍娜，这是你和我喜欢的那些经典场景之一，它以迈克尔开始，房间里还有谁。你不知道。然后它被揭示了。这次是安迪。安迪正在取代德怀特在迈克尔肩膀后的位置。但他让迈克尔感到毛骨悚然。你已经可以看出来了。嗯，迈克尔总是对德怀特在迈克尔说话时插嘴感到恼火，但这不一样。就像，迈克尔被德怀特烦，但迈克尔，就像，真的被安迪烦。嗯，你知道这对我来说感觉像什么，就像安迪正在让他心烦意乱。
Like, Dwight is like an annoying brother, but Andy is like the creeper that lives down the street. I don't know that you try to avoid when you go to the mailbox. Well, we had a fan question in this scene from Toneal, who wants to know, in this episode, there are a lot of talking heads with Michael facing the window where it's snowing. Were those talking heads shot in sequence so that they didn't have to keep turning the snow on and off? Yes. Yes.
就像，德怀特像一个烦人的兄弟，但安迪像住在街那头的那个怪人。我不知道当你去邮箱时你是否会尽量避开。嗯，我们在这一幕中有一个来自托尼尔的粉丝问题，他想知道，在这一集中，有很多迈克尔面对窗户下雪的谈话头。那些谈话头是按顺序拍摄的，这样他们就不必一直开关雪了吗？是的。是的。
I love this question, Angela, because we've never really talked about this. We always shot all of our talking heads in a row. So what they would do is they would set up the shot, let's say in Michael's office for a talking head, and every talking head he had for that episode, they would spend hours doing all of them. And the same thing in the conference room. Remember, they'd set up the chair and we would all cycle in for hours and do our talking heads. Yes, it would literally be like talking head day on set. And I always really felt for Steve because he always had the most.
我喜欢这个问题，安吉拉，因为我们从来没有真正谈论过这个。我们总是连续拍摄所有的谈话头。所以他们会做的是，他们会设置镜头，比如在迈克尔的办公室里拍摄谈话头，他那一集里的每一个谈话头，他们会花几个小时做完所有这些。会议室里也是一样。记得吗，他们会摆好椅子，我们所有人会轮流进去几个小时做我们的谈话头。是的，这简直就像片场的“谈话头日”。我总是真的很同情史蒂夫，因为他总是最多。
and I would think like, oh my God, I had to like learn one, you know, and maybe they would give me some alts on the day. But Steve had to learn so many and just sit there and do them and do them. And Veda would be there our scripty, our script supervisor. And sometimes she would remind you if you had more than one. Okay, now remember, this talking head is after Dwight left, so you're more sad than the one before, you know? So sometimes she was helping us kind of navigate the time sequence of it all. Yes. And we would usually do these either first thing in the morning or at the end of the day. Steve would always do his first thing in the morning. I think he liked to lead with them. He would oftentimes, I feel like on a Monday, it would be like Steve talking
我会想，哦，我的天，我得学一个，你知道，也许他们会在当天给我一些替代方案。但史蒂夫必须学那么多，只是坐在那里做它们，做它们。维达会在那里，我们的剧本主管。有时如果你不止一个，她会提醒你。好的，现在记住，这个谈话头是在德怀特离开之后，所以你比之前那个更难过，你知道吗？所以有时她会帮助我们理清这一切的时间顺序。是的。我们通常会在早上第一件事或一天结束时做这些。史蒂夫总是会在早上第一件事做他的。我想他喜欢带头做它们。他经常，我觉得在周一，就像史蒂夫做谈话头。
heads until almost lunch. And then we would all come in and film like group scenes for the rest of the day. Yeah. But then on Fridays, we would spend Friday afternoons all the rest of the cast doing our talking heads. That was kind of how we framed our week. Yeah, that's how I remember it too. Well, Jenna, you know, Oscar's back now and he walks back over to accounting. And of Kevin has a ridiculous joke that he's been saving for weeks. Kevin thought of it. He was like, how was your vacation? Oscar's like, awesome. Kevin's like, yeah, I thought of that. Two seconds after you left. Kevin's so proud of himself. And Angela is just like, hello. And he's like, hello. And you can tell that there's, I feel like a lot she wants to say, but she's not, she's not ready yet.
直到快午餐。然后我们所有人会进来拍摄像小组场景之类的一整天。是的。但在周五，我们会花周五下午剩下的演员做我们的谈话头。这就是我们安排一周的方式。是的，我也记得是那样。好吧，珍娜，你知道，奥斯卡现在回来了，他走回会计部。凯文有一个荒谬的笑话，他已经存了几个星期了。凯文想到了它。他说，你的假期怎么样？奥斯卡说，太棒了。凯文说，是的，我想到了。在你离开两秒钟后。凯文为自己感到骄傲。安吉拉只是说，你好。他说，你好。你可以看出，我觉得她有很多想说的话，但她还没有准备好。
She doesn't know how to say it yet. Yeah. But then eventually, Angela does invite Oscar to join the party planning committee. She says she's sorry for the way certain things transpired and she wants to make some changes. And she starts crying. Yeah. Well, Jenna, I really cried. That was me really crying.
她还不知道怎么说。是的。但最终，安吉拉确实邀请奥斯卡加入派对策划委员会。她说她为某些事情发生的方式感到抱歉，她想做一些改变。然后她开始哭。是的。好吧，珍娜，我真的哭了。那是我真的在哭。
and I had a whole conversation with Greg about it as we were trying to find the scene and I did one take and he was like Angela I'm feeling sad and he said this has to be a funny cry where sometimes on a show someone cries and it breaks your heart he said this needs to be just awkward
当我试图找到那个场景时，我和格雷格进行了整个对话，我拍了一次，他说，安吉拉，我感到很难过，他说这必须是一个有趣的哭泣，有时在剧里，有人哭，这会让你心碎，他说这需要只是尴尬。
and then at the end we have a joke because Kevin says can I join and I say never right Right. So it was sort of this interesting thing of figuring out, how do you cry, but you don't make people feel bad? You know? So, and what really helped me was that my lines were so ridiculous. So it was, you know, me being like certain events transpired and certain people and certain things, you know what I mean?
然后在最后我们有一个笑话，因为凯文说我可以加入吗，我说永远不要。对吧？所以这是一种弄清楚的有趣事情，你怎么哭，但你不让人们感到难过？你知道吗？所以，真正帮助我的是我的台词太荒谬了。所以，你知道，我就像某些事件发生了，某些人和某些事情，你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, yeah. But it was sort of this art for my character to find a way to cry that was just more awkward than sad. Well, you just made someone very happy. Sarah Cooper had written in to ask you, did you have to do anything different to get into character in preparation for this episode? You know, when you cry, we all have a little bit of our process of actors
是的，是的。但这对我这个角色来说是一种艺术，找到一种比悲伤更尴尬的哭泣方式。好吧，你刚刚让某人非常高兴。莎拉·库珀写信问你，为了准备这一集，你是否必须做任何不同的事情来进入角色？你知道，当你哭的时候，我们都有我们作为演员的一点过程。
of how we get to that place, but it was this sort of interesting thing to get myself there, but then kind of pull back a little bit. And this might be really boring, actor-y stuff, but it was a really interesting exercise. Well, we had another fan question, and Angela from Beatrix Smith, was it weird for you to have Oscar back? Did you miss him when he was
关于我们如何到达那个地方，但这是一种把自己带到那里的有趣事情，然后稍微退缩一点。这可能真的很无聊，演员的东西，但这确实是一个非常有趣的练习。好吧，我们有另一个粉丝问题，来自比阿特丽克斯·史密斯的安吉拉，奥斯卡回来对你来说很奇怪吗？你有没有想念他当他。
gone? Oh, yeah. I think Angela definitely missed Oscar. Listen, him being gone means, A, she's carrying most of the workload in accounting, because Kevin's no help, really. And I think that Oscar and Angela really are these sort of mismatched roommates, if you will. And you'll see their friendship come through throughout the seasons. But they are there for each other. It's just, I think they just had some hurdles to get over. Oh, well, that's a nice answer. I think she meant you, Angela. Did you miss your friend Oscar who hadn't been sitting there with you?
走了的时候？哦，是的。我想安吉拉肯定想念奥斯卡。听着，他走了意味着，A，她在会计部承担了大部分工作量，因为凯文真的帮不上忙。而且我认为奥斯卡和安吉拉确实是这些不匹配的室友，如果你愿意的话。你会看到他们的友谊在整个季节中显现出来。但他们确实在那里支持彼此。只是，我想他们只是有一些障碍需要克服。哦，好吧，那是一个很好的回答。我想她是说你，安吉拉。你有没有想念你的朋友奥斯卡，他没有坐在那里和你在一起？
But I like how you stayed in character there for that answer. Well, we were talking so much about Angela Martin. Well, of course I missed my friend. Are you kidding? I didn't have anyone to draw me little crazy cartoons of myself being silly and passing me now. But it was. You guys are such a little trio over there. Yeah. I definitely missed him. Well, while all of this is going on, Andy is just stalking Michael. Yeah. He's like looking for him everywhere and he follows him to the bathroom. Yeah. Jenna, Andy now has two expressions that I love. We first heard nifty Gifties from Andy. Love me the nifty Gifties. And in this one, Michael's like, what's up? And Andy goes, Nerfin. Nerfin
但我喜欢你为了那个回答保持角色的方式。好吧，我们谈论了太多关于安吉拉·马丁的事。好吧，我当然想念我的朋友。你在开玩笑吗？我没有人给我画关于我自己的疯狂小卡通，让我变得傻乎乎的，然后传给我。但它是。你们在那边真是个小三人组。是的。我绝对想念他。好吧，当所有这些都在发生时，安迪只是在跟踪迈克尔。是的。他到处找他，他跟着他进了洗手间。是的。珍娜，安迪现在有两个我喜欢的表情。我们第一次从安迪那里听到了“Nifty Gifties”。喜欢我的“Nifty Gifties”。在这一集中，迈克尔说，怎么了？安迪说，Nerfin。Nerfin。
Nerfin And now me and my kids are saying nerfin It just It has stuck here at the house I thought it was so funny But yeah Andy's driving Michael crazy And Michael has a whole talking head
Nerfin。现在我和我的孩子们都在说Nerfin。它就在家里扎根了。我觉得它太有趣了。但是是的，安迪让迈克尔发疯了。迈克尔有一个完整的谈话头。
From behind his door He's hiding It was it made me laugh out loud Because I didn't know where he was During this Because Andy's looking for him And he's just nowhere He's nowhere
从他的门后。他在躲藏。它让我大声笑出来。因为我不知道他在哪里。在这期间。因为安迪在找他。而他只是无处不在。他无处不在。
And then when he's revealed to be giving this whole talking head from behind his door. One of the things I loved about it most was that while hiding, he was still compelled to perform and speak to the camera. He was like, I'm hiding, but I'm not going to stop presenting myself to this camera crew. I wonder if he was like, I'm going to hide and you have to too, because if Andy sees you guys in here, so like, is there a room where the camera crew is like smushed up against the wall
然后当他被揭示出从他的门后进行整个谈话头时。我最喜欢的一点是，在躲藏时，他仍然被迫表演并对摄像机说话。他就像，我在躲藏，但我不会停止向这个摄制组展示自己。我想知道他是否像，我要躲起来，你们也必须躲起来，因为如果安迪看到你们在这里，所以，有一个房间是摄制组像挤在墙上一样。
also hiding? That's such a good point. All Andy has to look for is like, where's the camera pointed? Yeah. There's a crew constantly following Michael around. Well, we're coming up on a scene that completely destroyed John Krasinski in real life. I don't think he's ever laughed so hard ever, ever on the show. He has said it's the hard as he laughed the whole series.
也在躲藏吗？那是一个很好的观点。安迪所要寻找的只是，摄像机指向哪里？是的。有一个摄制组不断跟着迈克尔。好吧，我们即将迎来一个在现实生活中彻底摧毁约翰·卡拉辛斯基的场景。我不认为他在剧里笑得这么厉害过。他说这是他整个系列笑得最厉害的一次。
Like, and I texted Creed about it. Yeah, it's this scene in the kitchen where Oscar comes in and he's just kind of like, where's Dwight? and Creed says Dwight was decapitated and they had a funeral for a bird, which is not correct. But kind of correct, just all mushed up together. Yeah, Ed Truck was decapitated and they did have a funeral for a bird. And remember, Jim wasn't around for any of this. So Jim isn't even able to, like, correct this. So he just says, I'm pretty sure that's not real.
就像，我给克里德发了短信。是的，这是厨房里的场景，奥斯卡进来，他只是有点像，德怀特在哪里？克里德说德怀特被斩首了，他们为一只鸟举行了葬礼，这不正确。但有点正确，只是混在一起了。是的，埃德·特拉克被斩首了，他们确实为一只鸟举行了葬礼。记住，吉姆没有参与任何这些。所以吉姆甚至不能，像，纠正这个。所以他只是说，我很确定那不是真的。
and then Creed says, you're not real, man. And that is the line that destroyed John Krasinski. Yeah. John could not keep it together. He crumbled like into just fits of laughter. And I texted Creed. I was like, Creed, oh my gosh, we're breaking down the return. And you have that great line that you said to John.
然后克里德说，你不是真的，伙计。那句台词摧毁了约翰·卡拉辛斯基。是的。约翰无法控制自己。他崩溃成了一阵大笑。我给克里德发了短信。我说，克里德，哦天哪，我们正在分解那个回归。你对约翰说了那句很棒的台词。
And he was like, I said, what was that like? He said, oh, Ange, it was so much fun to see John lose it. like that. He said he lost it. There are a couple of times on the show where John has laughed so hard that like you can't. You just can't even film him because when he really loses it, he cannot be brought back. He can't. He's like he is what we said. He is destroyed. He's destroyed. He doubles over. He kind of tears up. He can't make noise. It was laughing like that. And I said, Creed, I mean, how did you, how many takes did you do? And he said, I think we got one where he kept it together.
他说，我说了，那是什么感觉？他说，哦，安吉，看到约翰那样失控太有趣了。他说他失控了。剧里有几次约翰笑得太厉害，以至于你不能。你甚至无法拍摄他，因为当他真的失控时，他无法被带回来。他不能。他就像我们说的。他被摧毁了。他被摧毁了。他弯下腰。他有点流泪。他不能发出声音。那是那样的笑。我说，克里德，我的意思是，你拍了多少次？他说，我想我们拍了一次他控制住自己的。
I think that's the one they used. Yeah, exactly, exactly. So now we have this little scene where Michael is noticing that, like, the plant in the office is dying. He says, you need to talk to the cleaning crew about this. And also, while you're at it, they used to arrange the toys on my desk in this really pleasing way. And I need to know why they've stopped. And Pam is like, well, no, that was Dwight. Dwight used to do that
我想那是他们用的那次。是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以现在我们有这个小场景，迈克尔注意到，像，办公室里的植物快死了。他说，你需要和清洁工谈谈这个。而且，当你这样做的时候，他们过去常以这种非常令人愉悦的方式整理我桌上的玩具。我需要知道为什么他们停止了。帕姆说，嗯，不，那是德怀特。德怀特过去常那样做。
And then of course Up from out of nowhere Comes Andy And he's like I agree And Michael's like What are we How do you know
然后当然，安迪从无处冒出来。他说，我同意。迈克尔说，我们是什么。你怎么知道。
What do you agree with How do you even know What we're talking about Yeah and Andy's like Pam was like blah blah Something lame And then you're like Right on
你同意什么？你甚至怎么知道我们在谈论什么？是的，安迪说，帕姆刚才说，blah blah，一些蹩脚的东西。然后你说，说得对。
There it is There it is Come on Seven minutes 33 seconds The very first But not the last So we're back at the party planning committee meeting. Angela is sad.
就在那里。就在那里。来吧。7分33秒。第一次。但不是最后一次。所以我们回到了派对策划委员会会议。安吉拉很难过。
She is sad. She's not even speaking up about anything. She's not even being mean to Phyllis. You know the woman is sad. Can I say something? Yeah. I think that later when we see this party, it's going to be one of the best ones we've ever thrown.
她很难过。她甚至没有对任何事情发表意见。她甚至没有对菲利斯刻薄。你知道这个女人很难过。我可以说话吗？是的。我想以后当我们看到这个派对时，它将是我们举办过的最好的派对之一。
How dare you? I'm just saying, I'm just saying that you're a little checked out. And look what we did without you. When we, when others were allowed to participate in the planning, we threw a very, like, the decorations that Creed loved the food. Let me do you something, lady. What? What? I am flabbergasted.
你怎么敢？我只是说，我只是说你有点心不在焉。看看没有你我们做了什么。当我们，当其他人被允许参与策划时，我们举办了一个非常，像，克里德喜欢的装饰，食物。让我为你做点什么，女士。什么？什么？我惊呆了。
Well, I mean, I just want to say, I noted. I noted how disengaged from the planning Angela was, and then I noticed what a really great party it was. Well, you know, Michael has given the marching orders. He really wants to celebrate Oscar, as Michael says, quote, his Mexican-ness. He wants firecrackers, a chihuahua. You know, he also tells them to get a donkey. A burrow. Because, you know, the reason that we're throwing a Mexican theme party is because Oscar's gayness does not define him.
好吧，我的意思是，我只是想说，我注意到了。我注意到安吉拉对策划有多么不投入，然后我注意到这是一个多么棒的派对。好吧，你知道，迈克尔已经下达了行军命令。他真的想庆祝奥斯卡，正如迈克尔所说，引用，“他的墨西哥性”。他想要鞭炮，一只吉娃娃。你知道，他还告诉他们弄一头驴。一头毛驴。因为，你知道，我们举办墨西哥主题派对的原因是因为奥斯卡的同性恋身份并不能定义他。
him, his Mexicanness is what defines him. And Oscar's just like... According to Michael. Great. Great. Right back in it with Michael. Oscar's thinking of all the things he's going to purchase after this party. I know.
他的墨西哥性才是定义他的东西。奥斯卡只是像……根据迈克尔。太棒了。太棒了。又回到了迈克尔身边。奥斯卡在想他在这场派对后要买的所有东西。我知道。
Well, I have a question for you about a scene coming up, Jenna. Okay. Is it in the script that Andy, like, fishes for Jim? Like, that he throws the rod and reel and the whole thing? Or was that just made up on the day? Angela, I will check the script for that. And in the meantime, while I'm doing that, please enjoy this whole music by Carmen and Camille doing their version of Heartbreak in the Break Room. One moment. Merger Day came, I had you on the brain and grape soda.
好吧，我有一个关于即将到来的场景的问题，珍娜。好的。剧本里有写安迪，像，为吉姆钓鱼吗？他扔了鱼竿和卷轴和整件事？还是那是当天编出来的？安吉拉，我会检查剧本。同时，在我做那个的时候，请享受卡门和卡米尔演唱的《休息室里的心碎》版本。等一下。合并日到了，我脑子里有你和葡萄汽水。
My coloride, I felt hunchy inside like I didn't know you. my mama she nipped me a sexy sweater but only got me it was heartbreak in the break all right thank you for holding i could not find that in the script it wasn't in the script no so it was either conceived of as a rewrite page or it was something he did on the the day. So what's in the script, the thing that makes Jim want to prank Andy is just more singing at his desk, that he's just obnoxiously singing, and then Jim decides he has to do something. Right. But the fishing for tuna, not in the script. Okay. Well, it's perfect for Andy. It's so perfect. Jim has had it, though, and he now wants to play a prank. He asked Karen. Karen says she's too busy.
我的颜色，我感觉里面很驼背，好像我不认识你。我妈妈，她给我织了一件性感的毛衣，但只给了我，那是休息室里的心碎。好的，谢谢你的等待。我在剧本里找不到那个。剧本里没有。不，所以它要么被构思为重写页，要么是他在当天做的事情。所以剧本里有什么，让吉姆想捉弄安迪的事情只是他在桌子上唱歌，他只是令人讨厌地唱歌，然后吉姆决定他必须做点什么。对。但钓金枪鱼，剧本里没有。好的。好吧，这对安迪来说很完美。太完美了。不过吉姆受够了，他现在想捉弄一下。他问凯伦。凯伦说她太忙了。
She got all of Dwight's clients. Then he asked Ryan, and lady, we have some. some Ryan Sass. I loved it. I'm falling in love with Ryan. I know you are. Not going to lie. I know you are. What does he say?
她得到了德怀特所有的客户。然后他问瑞安，女士，我们有一些。一些瑞安的傲慢。我喜欢它。我爱上了瑞安。我知道你是。不撒谎。我知道你是。他说什么？
I'll tell you what he said. He says, oh, you know what? Not right now, but ask me again 10 years ago. So good. And I feel like John's, the look on John's face as Jim in that moment is so good. So good. He's like, all right, man. I liked you better when you were the temp.
我会告诉你他说了什么。他说，哦，你知道吗？不是现在，但10年前再问我一次。太好了。我觉得约翰的，吉姆在那一刻的表情太好了。太好了。他就像，好吧，伙计。我更喜欢你当临时工的时候。
Ryan's like, so did I. So did I. He says, so did I. That's some serious Ryan's ass. So, Angela, should we check in with Dwight now? See how he's doing over at Staples? Yes. He's doing great.
瑞安说，我也是。我也是。他说，我也是。那是一些严重的瑞安傲慢。所以，安吉拉，我们现在应该看看德怀特吗？看看他在史泰博过得怎么样？是的。他做得很好。
He's crushing it. He is. We had some fan questions about Staples from Amy Jackson, Aaron Westra, Ainsley Thompson, Jeff Needham, Diamond P, and Kate N. They wanted to know, did we film in an actual Staples store? yes yes we did we filmed at a real staples it was at the empire center in burbank i've actually been there many times not only to the empire center but to this actual staples i have purchased my home printer at this staples jenna i feel like we went there for like a bff afternoon where we went to target and then we went to stables together i have like a memory of that oh yeah i'm sure we did that
他正在摧毁它。他是。我们有一些关于史泰博的粉丝问题，来自艾米·杰克逊、亚伦·韦斯特拉、安斯利·汤普森、杰夫·尼达姆、戴蒙德·P和凯特·N。他们想知道，我们是在真正的史泰博商店拍摄的吗？是的，是的，我们是在真正的史泰博拍摄的。它在伯班克的帝国中心。我实际上去过那里很多次，不仅是去帝国中心，而且是去这个真正的史泰博。我在这个史泰博买过我的家用打印机。珍娜，我觉得我们去那里过了一个闺蜜下午，我们去了塔吉特，然后我们一起去了史泰博。我有那种记忆。哦，是的，我肯定我们做了那个。
because then there's that donut place that you like. What is it? Krispy cream. Krispy cream. What's not to like? Exactly. And they have a drive-thru. They have a drive-thru.
因为那里有你喜欢的那个甜甜圈店。是什么？Krispy Kreme。Krispy Kreme。有什么不喜欢的？完全正确。而且他们有得来速。他们有得来速。
They have a drive-thru, and they also have this conveyor belt that you can watch. It's like watching a car wash, but it's donuts going by. And then you get to the end, and they just take it right off the conveyor belt, and it's super warm. And they hand it to you, and kids love it. It's like a mini donut factory. Well, I would take my kids there all the time. I think the first time we went, you and I didn't even have kids. Well, this is true.
他们有得来速，他们还有一个你可以观看的传送带。就像看洗车，但那是甜甜圈经过。然后你到了尽头，他们直接把它从传送带上拿下来，它超级热。他们把它递给你，孩子们喜欢它。这就像一个迷你甜甜圈工厂。好吧，我会一直带我的孩子们去那里。我想我们第一次去的时候，你和我甚至还没有孩子。好吧，这是真的。
This is true. Okay, so, yeah, Dwight is crushing it. Sorry, we got off on a tangent about donuts. Go figure. We did. But I want to say, remember back in the merger when we talked about how Staples paid the production to feature one of its shredders in an episode? People were asking if this was still part of that product integration? No.
这是真的。好的，所以，是的，德怀特正在摧毁它。抱歉，我们跑题谈论甜甜圈了。想一想。我们做了。但我想要说，记得在合并时我们谈论过史泰博是如何支付制作费用以在剧集中展示其碎纸机之一的吗？人们在问这是否仍然是产品整合的一部分？不。
No. This was just a plot point. They just thought it would be funny that Dwight ends up going to work for Dunder Mifflin's competitor. So Staples did not pay to be featured in this episode at all. And then, guess what they did? What? They did something insane to the Staples. What did they do?
不。这只是一个情节点。他们只是认为德怀特最终去为邓德·米夫林的竞争对手工作会很有趣。所以史泰博根本没有支付费用出现在这一集中。然后，猜猜他们做了什么？什么？他们对史泰博做了一些疯狂的事情。他们做了什么？
So I'm going to let Greg tell you. We arranged to have a real Staples be the location for this episode. And I had scouted it. And then between the time, that I scouted it and the time that we showed up to shoot, they had replaced all the staple signage with very unrealistic looking staple signs that were three times bigger than what we had seen because they wanted more of an advertising pop in the background of our show in the morning of the day we were supposed to shoot there. And so it became like the thing
所以我让格雷格告诉你。我们安排了一个真正的史泰博作为这一集的拍摄地点。我勘察过它。然后在我勘察它和我们出现拍摄的时间之间，他们用非常不现实的史泰博标志替换了所有的史泰博标志，这些标志比我们看到的要大三倍，因为他们想要在我们剧集的背景中有更多的广告效果，在我们应该在那里拍摄的那天早上。所以它变成了像那件事一样。
about, you know, we had to make our day and we had to shoot, but I didn't want to turn the show into an ad for Staples. So there was a lot of shooting around it. And I believe the last shot where the camera kind of zooms into a security camera to see them exiting was to avoid a gigantic staple sign that they had put up at the last minute. Ooh, Staples, you were so sneaky. Oh, Staples, can you blame them? They're like, hey, we got a camera crew here.
关于，你知道，我们必须赶进度，必须进行拍摄，但我不想把这部剧变成史泰博（Staples）的广告。所以拍摄时有很多避开它的镜头。我相信最后一个镜头，摄像机缩放到一个监控摄像头上，看到他们离开，就是为了避开他们在最后一刻竖起的一个巨大的史泰博标志。噢，史泰博，你们真是太狡猾了。噢，史泰博，你能怪他们吗？他们会想，嘿，我们这儿有个摄制组。
I'm going to put up my big sign. I'd probably do the same thing. I would do the same thing. They were like, Henry, get all. over here. Bring the tall ladder and the big signs. Yeah. Get it on TV. Um, you know I love the Staples folks because they give back to teachers, Jenna. So, oh, yeah. I love them. But that is very funny. I have a little piece of trivia, though, about that day. Dave Rogers said that Greg got really sick that day, so sick that he had to go home halfway through the day and Randall
我要竖起我的大招牌。我可能也会做同样的事。我也会做同样的事。他们当时就像是，亨利，把所有东西都搬到这儿来。带上高梯子和大招牌。对，让它上电视。嗯，你知道我喜欢史泰博的人，因为他们回馈老师，珍娜。所以，噢，是的。我喜欢他们。但这非常有趣。不过，关于那天我有一个小花絮。戴夫·罗杰斯说格雷格那天病得很重，病到他不得不中途回家，然后兰德尔
took over. Whoa. Yeah. That's crazy. I know. Well, listen, I want to talk a little bit about Dwight's new co-worker Paris. She's amazing. Played by Yvette Nicole Brown, who would later go to star in Community. Mm-hmm. This scene with them in the break room, eating lunch, I watched it three times.
接手了。哇。是的。太疯狂了。我知道。好吧，听着，我想聊聊德怀特的新同事帕里斯。她太棒了。由伊薇特·妮可·布朗饰演，她后来主演了《废柴联盟》。嗯哼。这个他们在休息室吃午饭的场景，我看了三遍。
I watched it three times because she is so funny. Her, like, you know what it is? I feel like we're getting this opportunity to have someone outside of the Dunder-Mifflin family react to Dwight Shrewt. We all know what Dwight is like. We know what to expect from him. So to place Dwight in the real world with a regular person who's not used to him was so funny to me. And her reactions were what I would imagine anyone would react like if they met Dwight. Yes.
我看了三遍，因为她太搞笑了。她，就像，你知道是怎么回事吗？我觉得我们得到了一个机会，让邓德·米夫林家族以外的人对德怀特·舒鲁特做出反应。我们都知道德怀特是什么样的人。我们知道对他有什么期待。所以把德怀特放在现实世界中，和一个不习惯他的人在一起，这对我来说太搞笑了。她的反应就是我所想象的任何人遇到德怀特时会有的反应。是的。
I texted her. I said, Evette, I just want you to know, I forgot about this scene and how great it was and rewatching it. It was hilarious. And she was like, oh, Angela, I feel like I was just there for a blip. And I said, Evette, you stole the scene. You stole the scene. Yes.
我给她发了短信。我说，伊薇特，我只是想让你知道，我忘了这个场景，也忘了它有多棒，重看的时候。它太搞笑了。她说，噢，安吉拉，我觉得我只是在那儿待了一小会儿。我说，伊薇特，你抢了戏。你抢了戏。是的。
Now, you mentioned, Angela, that you were watching this episode with your kids. My son walked into my office while I was watching this scene. He was laughing. And then he and I. Looked for a fan catch that was sent in by Lori Lex. Oh, what did you guys find? Oh, my gosh. My son was so tickled because during this scene,
现在，你提到了，安吉拉，你在和你的孩子们一起看这一集。我儿子在我看这一幕的时候走进我的办公室。他在笑。然后我和他。寻找一个由洛里·莱克斯寄来的粉丝发现。噢，你们发现了什么？噢，天哪。我儿子被逗乐了，因为在这一幕中，
Dwight's sandwich that he's eating gets bigger rather than smaller as he eats it. Because they use different takes. So at 12 minutes, 21 seconds, all that's left is like a little corner of bread. And then at 12 minutes, 28 seconds, it's much larger. I love it. I love how into this episode our kids were with background catches. I know. It's so cute.
德怀特正在吃的三明治在他吃的时候反而变大了，而不是变小了。因为他们用了不同的拍摄片段。所以在12分21秒时，剩下的只有一小块面包角。然后在12分28秒时，它大多了。我喜欢这个。我喜欢我们的孩子对这一集的背景细节发现有多投入。我知道。太可爱了。
Well, lady, I want to talk about the scene with Michael and Angela. They're in the break room, and they're clearly both missing Dwight. But obviously, neither of them are saying that to each other. And Michael just says, oh, it's good to have Oscar back. And Angela's like, yeah. And they both just sort of sadly take a sip of their beverage and look off into space. And I never, ever got quiet moment scenes with Steve. And so in re-watching this, it was so special to me because I just, our characters hardly ever interacted.
好吧，女士，我想聊聊迈克尔和安吉拉的那个场景。他们在休息室，显然他们都很想念德怀特。但显然，他们谁都没有对对方说出来。迈克尔只是说，噢，奥斯卡回来真好。安吉拉说，是啊。然后他们俩都有些悲伤地喝了一口饮料，望着虚空。我从来没有和史蒂夫有过安静的时刻。所以重看这一幕，对我来说非常特别，因为我只是，我们的角色几乎从不互动。
And when they did, I was usually mad at him, you know? Yeah. So that was really special. And then on a total tangent, there is a fantastic shot at 13 minutes, 47 seconds of Luann's Water fountain. And it's there like gurgling away. Lady, I saw the same thing. I saw the same thing. I think that's what was in the background of that kitchen scene and that other episode that we all thought was a fireplace. I think it was Luanne's water feature. She had a Zen garden and a water fountain. She did. And they never plugged it in
而当他们互动时，我通常都在生他的气，你知道吗？是的。所以那真的很特别。然后完全跑题一下，在13分47秒有一个非常棒的镜头，是卢安的喷泉。它在那儿咕噜咕噜地响。女士，我看到了同样的东西。我看到了同样的东西。我想那可能就是另一集中那个厨房场景背景里的东西，我们都以为是壁炉。我想那是卢安的水景。她有一个禅宗花园和一个喷泉。她确实有。而且他们从来没插上电，
because it made noise. But every once in a while, I guess it got plugged in. And I think you're right, because it has a little blue light in it that maybe we thought was a fire something. Yes. Oh, my God. I love that we both got excited about Luann's fountain. Well, Jenna, I think on that note of getting super excited about a fountain in the background, we should take a break. Yeah, we'll take a break and then we'll come back and get into this big prank. All right, guys, we are back.
因为它会发出噪音。但我想偶尔它还是会被插上电。我想你是对的，因为它里面有一个小蓝灯，也许我们以为那是火之类的东西。是的。噢，天哪。我喜欢我们俩都对卢安的喷泉感到兴奋。好吧，珍娜，既然我们对背景里的喷泉感到如此兴奋，我们应该休息一下。是的，我们休息一下，然后回来深入探讨这个大恶作剧。好了，伙计们，我们回来了。
Angela, do you know what I'm doing right now? No. I mean, I can see you, but... I'm making bread. I can't see your hands, but I know your left one is moving. No, not, I'm not literally making bread in my lap. I'm sitting here podcasting, but I am simultaneously bread making. Like, that's the cool thing about bread making is that I have dough that is rising into a little
安吉拉，你知道我现在在做什么吗？不知道。我是说，我能看到你，但是……我在做面包。我看不见你的手，但我知道你的左手在动。不，不是，我不是真的在腿上做面包。我坐在这儿录播客，但我同时在做面包。就像，做面包最酷的地方在于，我有面团正在发酵成一个小
living dough baby that I'm going to put. in my oven and turn into crisp, delicious sourdough bread as we speak. That science is working in my kitchen on my counter right now. During this break, I molded my little dough baby. Aw. Yeah. Well, I molded another dough baby. I like to call my belly because I went downstairs and ate a little piece of this, I don't even know what it is that Josh made. It's like some kind of, it tastes like a little square of pecan pie. It's so good. Can we give a plug to Josh's baking page, please? Baking with Josh and Ang, there is a recipe on there for something called a brookie. Mm-hmm. Okay. You know, I made this the other day. It is a layer of brownie topped with a layer of
活生生的面团宝宝，我一会儿要把它放进烤箱，烤成酥脆美味的酸种面包。科学正在我的厨房台面上运作。在休息期间，我塑造了我的小面团宝宝。噢。是的。好吧，我又塑造了另一个面团宝宝。我喜欢称我的肚子为面团宝宝，因为我下楼吃了一小块这个，我甚至不知道乔什做了什么。它就像某种，尝起来像一小块山核桃派。太好吃了。我们能为乔什的烘焙页面打个广告吗，拜托？“与乔什和安吉一起烘焙”，上面有一个叫“布鲁基”（brookie）的东西的食谱。嗯哼。好吧。你知道，我前几天做了这个。它是一层布朗尼，上面盖着一层
chocolate chip cookie and their bars. Angela, I ate so many of them that I made myself sick. I made myself sick like I was like a child who couldn't stop eating candy on Halloween. And I felt so ill. And even when I felt sick from eating so many of them, I wanted to eat more of them. That's how good the brooky is, guys. It'll make you sick and you won't care and you'll keep eating it anyway. I don't know what kind of endorsement that is, but I feel like that's a good endorsement. Yeah, well, he has tons of recipes.
巧克力豆曲奇，它们是条状的。安吉拉，我吃得太多了，把自己吃吐了。我把自己吃吐了，就像一个万圣节吃糖停不下来的孩子。我感觉太难受了。即使我因为吃太多而感到恶心，我还是想吃更多。布鲁基就是这么好吃，伙计们。它会让你恶心，但你不会在乎，你还是会继续吃。我不知道这算什么推荐，但我觉得这是一个很好的推荐。是的，好吧，他有很多食谱。
You guys, my husband is a baker. You can go to baking with Josh and Ange.com for all of his recipes. I don't even know why I'm in the equation there. It's just that when he bakes, he likes me around. But he is the master. I'm the taste tester and he's the master. That was really sweet, Jenna. Well, if you want to eat so much of something that you make yourself sick,
伙计们，我丈夫是个烘焙师。你们可以去 BakingwithJoshandAnge.com 查看他所有的食谱。我甚至不知道我为什么在等式里。只是当他烘焙时，他喜欢我在身边。但他才是大师。我是试吃员，他是大师。那真的很贴心，珍娜。好吧，如果你想吃某种东西吃到把自己吃吐，
make the brookie. But he also has, guys, not just sweets. He's got like these one sheet meals. And I love to cook things on one sheet. because then I only have to clean one thing. Yes, they are really good. We just did his one sheet chicken fajitas. That's my favorite.
就做布鲁基。但他也有，伙计们，不仅仅是甜点。他还有像这种单盘餐。我喜欢在单盘上做饭，因为那样我只需要清洗一样东西。是的，它们真的很好吃。我们刚做了他的单盘鸡肉法希塔。那是我的最爱。
It's so good. All right. This became a small commercial for baking with Josh and Ange.com, but I stand by it. Well, thanks. That's really sweet. I'll tell him. He'll be tickled. All right.
太好吃了。好吧。这变成了一个关于 BakingwithJoshandAnge.com 的小广告，但我支持它。好吧，谢谢。那真的很贴心。我会告诉他的。他会很高兴的。好吧。
Well, let's get back to this episode. Jim steals Andy's cell phone. Yeah. But why does he pass it off to Pam? I don't understand why they trade it twice. What are they secret spies? Couldn't he have just taken it and gone straight to the bathroom and like checked it up in the ceiling or something? Yes, this entire prank could have been done by Jim alone.
好吧，让我们回到这一集。吉姆偷了安迪的手机。是的。但他为什么要把它传给帕姆？我不明白他们为什么要交换两次。他们是秘密间谍吗？他不能直接拿走然后直接去洗手间，把它扔在天花板里或者什么地方吗？是的，整个恶作剧完全可以由吉姆一个人完成。
He tried to recruit all these people to do this prank with him that required only one person. He could have prank Dandy on his own. But for Jim, the prank is like the social bonding experience. It's not about like just doing it by himself. What's the fun in that? Exactly. He wants a partner. He wants a buddy. Yes. So he does this weird thing where he knocks over the pens and steals the phone and then gives it to Pam and then Pam gives it back to him. And Karen clocks it. Yeah, Karen notices. She doesn't know what they're doing, but they're in cahoots.
他试图招募所有这些人来和他一起做这个只需要一个人就能完成的恶作剧。他完全可以自己捉弄安迪。但对吉姆来说，恶作剧就像是一种社交联谊体验。这不仅仅是关于他自己做这件事。那样有什么乐趣呢？完全正确。他想要一个伙伴。他想要一个哥们。是的。所以他做了这个奇怪的事情，他撞倒了笔，偷了手机，然后给了帕姆，然后帕姆又把它还给了他。凯伦注意到了。是的，凯伦注意到了。她不知道他们在做什么，但他们是一伙的。
Well, and then you're like his lookout, but you can clearly see him. You guys have the most, like, you're the most oddball, like, duo. I feel like there could have been a spinoff where Jim and Pam are secret spies, but everyone knows. Well, and just to our point earlier, is no one noticing the camera crew following Jim and Pam sneaking and, like, filming them, do this prank? There's a lot of disbelief you have to suspend right here in this moment. Jenna, no one sees it because Pam is so great at distracting them by drinking her water. That's all we see. Pam's just drinking her water and playing with her necklace. Nothing to see here.
好吧，然后你就像他的望风者，但你可以清楚地看到他。你们俩，就像，你们是最古怪的二人组。我觉得可以有一个衍生剧，吉姆和帕姆是秘密间谍，但大家都知道。好吧，回到我们刚才的观点，难道没有人注意到摄制组跟着吉姆和帕姆鬼鬼祟祟地，像是在拍摄他们做这个恶作剧吗？在这个时刻，你必须悬置很多怀疑。珍娜，没有人看到，因为帕姆太擅长通过喝水来分散他们的注意力了。我们看到的只有这些。帕姆只是在喝水，玩弄她的项链。没什么好看的。
Yeah. What do you mean? What? Well, you have to remember in the last episode, Phyllis kind of spills the beans and says to Karen, I'm so glad you and Jim are together because he was hung up on Pam for so long. So, you know, Karen has got that in her brain. And when she sees the two of them kind of giggling and up to something, she's like, oh, no. what's happening. Yes. Well, meanwhile, Kelly and Oscar are setting up for the party. I think it's
是的。你什么意思？什么？好吧，你必须记住在上一集中，菲利斯有点说漏了嘴，对凯伦说，我很高兴你和吉姆在一起，因为他一直对帕姆念念不忘。所以，你知道，凯伦脑子里有这个想法。当她看到他们俩在那儿咯咯笑，好像在搞什么名堂时，她会想，噢，不，发生了什么。是的。好吧，与此同时，凯利和奥斯卡正在为派对做准备。我觉得
very funny that Oscar has to set up his own party. He has chores at his own party. It's amazing. And then Michael, meanwhile, is pouting in the kitchen. He wants to let Jim know that he's not fine. He's not fine. And he's like, he doesn't want to talk about it. But Jim's like, okay. And he's like, okay, and he's like, okay. Yeah. And he's like, what do you think of Andy? What do you think of Andy? And I love this, Angela. is like, well, I mean, he's kind of a yes man. And Michael's like, that's not true because when I say I don't like something, he says he doesn't like it too. It's like, oh, Michael.
奥斯卡必须为自己的派对做准备非常有趣。他在自己的派对上还要干活。太神奇了。然后迈克尔，与此同时，在厨房里生闷气。他想让吉姆知道他并不好。他并不好。他就像，他不想谈论这件事。但吉姆说，好吧。他就像，好吧，他就像，好吧。是的。他就像，你觉得安迪怎么样？你觉得安迪怎么样？我喜欢这个，安吉拉。就像，嗯，我的意思是，他是个应声虫。迈克尔说，那不是真的，因为当我说我不喜欢某样东西时，他也说他不喜欢。就像，噢，迈克尔。
Oh, Michael. Steve is so brilliant in this episode. I know we talk about how good he is so, like every week, but he had to, I don't even know how to say it, but the way he reacts to Andy is like a whole new version. of Michael Scott we haven't seen. And he's so brilliant. And the way he doesn't get things and then the audience gets it before him and then he finally gets it, it's just amazing.
噢，迈克尔。史蒂夫在这一集中太出色了。我知道我们每周都在谈论他有多好，但他必须，我甚至不知道该怎么说，但他对安迪的反应就像是一个我们从未见过的迈克尔·斯科特的全新版本。他太出色了。他那种不明白事情，然后观众比他先明白，最后他终于明白了的方式，简直太棒了。
Well, Angela, he has this talking head that I can't even barely watch because... Was it about the Raspberry? Yeah. The Sherbert thing. It's about the way Steve delivers it is so masterful, but the whole thing just makes me so uncomfortable. Whenever Michael talks about his childhood, I get scared. I just feel like I don't want more details about his loneliness and his like need for attention and his all of it. His awkward interactions with his mom and stepdad Jeff. I mean. Yeah. Yeah. I know. Poor Michael. I know
好吧，安吉拉，他有一个谈话头镜头，我甚至几乎不敢看，因为……是关于覆盆子的吗？是的。那个果汁冰糕的事。关于史蒂夫表达它的方式太精湛了，但整件事让我感到非常不舒服。每当迈克尔谈论他的童年时，我就感到害怕。我只是觉得我不想知道更多关于他的孤独，以及他对关注的需求，还有他的一切细节。他和他妈妈以及继父杰夫之间尴尬的互动。我是说。是的。是的。我知道。可怜的迈克尔。我知道
this is totally off topic, but I was impressed that Jim's choice of snack, was raw carrots. Yes, Angela. Angela, we had a fan point this out about the carrots. Brianna Kernan wrote in to say, does John really like to snack on carrots? Because he can be seen in multiple episodes snacking on carrots at various times.
这完全跑题了，但我对吉姆选择的零食是生胡萝卜印象深刻。是的，安吉拉。安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝指出了胡萝卜的事。布里安娜·科南写信来说，约翰真的喜欢吃胡萝卜吗？因为他在多集中多次被看到在不同时间吃胡萝卜。
I did a lot of scenes with John, and so I can tell you that he eats carrots. If given the choice for what he gets to eat in a scene, he will pick something healthy. He will pick carrots a lot. He would pick carrots. To the point that they finally had to say, John, you can't with the carrots. It's like really bad for sound.
我和约翰拍了很多戏，所以我可以告诉你，他确实吃胡萝卜。如果让他选择在戏里吃什么，他会选一些健康的东西。他会经常选胡萝卜。他会选胡萝卜。以至于他们最后不得不说，约翰，你不能再吃胡萝卜了。这对收音效果真的很不好。
So then he started eating grapes. Oh, wow. So you'll see him eat some grapes. But occasionally it would be scripted that we're eating chips. Mm-hmm. And he would eat the chips, but he preferred a healthy snack, guys. He just did. I am very impressed, John.
所以后来他开始吃葡萄。噢，哇。所以你会看到他吃一些葡萄。但偶尔剧本会写我们在吃薯片。嗯哼。他会吃薯片，但他更喜欢健康的零食，伙计们。他就是这样。我印象非常深刻，约翰。
I'm very impressed. I mean, I usually would ask for potato chips. Yeah. Well, BJ Novak and I used to say that if it's a prop, it doesn't have any calories, so you can eat as much of it as you want. Oh, interesting theory. Yeah, it's not real food. You're pretending.
我印象非常深刻。我是说，我通常会要薯片。是的。好吧，BJ·诺瓦克和我过去常说，如果是道具，它就没有卡路里，所以你可以想吃多少就吃多少。噢，有趣的理论。是的，那不是真正的食物。你在假装。
It's pretend food. It's pretend food. No calories. Pretend calories. You can, you know what I would pick now is a brookie. I'd be like, can I snack on a brookie, please? Well, the party's set up is underway, but Angela and Pam have a little conversational. station out by the elevators. And I loved it so much, Jenna, when Pam's like, is it about Dwight?
那是假装的食物。那是假装的食物。没有卡路里。假装的卡路里。你可以，你知道我现在会选什么吗，是布鲁基。我会说，我可以吃个布鲁基吗，拜托？好吧，派对准备工作正在进行中，但安吉拉和帕姆在电梯旁进行了一次小谈话。我太喜欢了，珍娜，当帕姆说，是因为德怀特吗？
And Angela's like, no, John Denver. You're like, okay, that's how it's going to be. I'm out. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no. But is John Denver like one of her favorite singers? Like, where did John Denver come from? It's just such a funny sort of little bit of detail to me about Angela Martin. Well, Angela tells Pam that she's really missing Dwight and she feels bad. Yeah. And Pam, and Pam, says, I think you should talk to Michael. And Angela's like, Pam, I'm not like you walking around in your provocative outfits, saying whatever thought pops in your head. Yeah.
安吉拉说，不，约翰·丹佛。你就像，好吧，事情就是这样了。我走了。是的。不，不，不，不，不。但约翰·丹佛是她最喜欢的歌手之一吗？约翰·丹佛是从哪儿冒出来的？这对我来说是关于安吉拉·马丁的一个非常有趣的细节。好吧，安吉拉告诉帕姆她真的很想念德怀特，她感觉很糟糕。是的。帕姆说，我觉得你应该和迈克尔谈谈。安吉拉说，帕姆，我可不像你，穿着挑逗的衣服走来走去，想到什么就说什么。是的。
I love that. As she's wearing a sweater over a button down, like, what are these outfits, Angela? What are you even talking about? Yes. But anyway, Angela appreciates Pam's, you know, talking with her and gives her such a weird hug. It's like she hugs her, and then when she realizes she's hugging you, she shoves you away. Well, we had a fan question about it, Angela. Caleb Feener and Kylie Campbell both asked, was that hug improvised or was it in the script?
我喜欢那个。当她穿着一件套在衬衫外面的毛衣时，就像，这些是什么衣服，安吉拉？你在说什么？是的。但无论如何，安吉拉很感激帕姆和她谈话，并给了她一个非常奇怪的拥抱。就像她拥抱了她，然后当她意识到她在拥抱你时，她就把你推开了。好吧，我们有一个关于它的粉丝问题，安吉拉。凯莱布·菲纳和凯莉·坎贝尔都问，那个拥抱是即兴的还是剧本里的？
What do you think, Angela? Improvised or in the script? I feel like it was improvised. It was improvised. It was not in the script. It was not in the script that was improvised. Yeah, yeah. I feel like you and I played around with that scene a few different ways.
你觉得呢，安吉拉？即兴的还是剧本里的？我觉得是即兴的。是即兴的。剧本里没有。剧本里没有，那是即兴的。是的，是的。我觉得你和我用几种不同的方式演了那个场景。
It was so fun. That was great. That was great. Well, back in the bullpen, Jim just keeps calling Andy's phone, which is ringing now up in the ceiling. And a lot of people asked, was the phone really in the ceiling playing the song? Now, normally, I feel like the answer would be no, because it would ruin your ability to edit the scene. But Angela, I really. I remember that phone playing up in the ceiling.
太有趣了。那太棒了。那太棒了。好吧，回到办公区，吉姆一直在打安迪的电话，现在电话在天花板里响着。很多人问，电话真的在天花板里播放那首歌吗？通常，我觉得答案是否定的，因为那会破坏你剪辑场景的能力。但安吉拉，我真的。我记得那个电话在天花板里响。
Am I going crazy? No, I feel like I remember it too. I feel like they put a speaker up in the ceiling and they had someone play that song for us to react to. I have like such a strong memory of hearing it all day long. Like over our heads. Yes. Yeah.
我是不是疯了？不，我觉得我也记得。我觉得他们在天花板里放了一个扬声器，他们让人播放那首歌让我们做出反应。我有一种非常强烈的记忆，整天都能听到它。就在我们头顶上。是的。是的。
Yes. So guys, I know one can remember. I reached out to a bunch of people about this. What's the deal? No one is sure, but I'm going with my personal memory that we really did have, I don't know if it was the phone, but we really were listening to that four-part harmony up in the ceiling and reacting to it. Yeah.
是的。所以伙计们，我知道有人记得。我联系了很多人问这件事。到底是怎么回事？没人确定，但我坚持我的个人记忆，我们确实有，我不知道那是不是电话，但我们确实在听天花板里的四部和声，并对此做出反应。是的。
We weren't reacting to nothing. It was actually getting really annoying. I do remember that. I was like so sick of that song. That's what I was like, oh, my God. Angela, when we were rewatched this episode and it played for the first time, I kind of like, I recoiled a little bit. Like my, the cells in my body were like, oh, no, not again.
我们不是对空气做出反应。它实际上变得非常烦人。我确实记得那个。我当时就像，噢，天哪。安吉拉，当我们重看这一集，它第一次播放时，我有点，我退缩了。就像我的，我身体里的细胞就像，噢，不，不要再来了。
Not again. Since memory. Yes, because I remember shooting this episode and singing it. And then when I went to bed, the night I rewatched it, I was like, I've done the two times all a day long. Rocking in an event, I was singing a song. I was like, don't do this to me again. We cannot skip past what I like to call nimble Phyllis.
不要再来了。记忆。是的，因为我记得拍摄这一集并唱它。然后当我上床睡觉时，重看的那天晚上，我心想，我一天唱了两遍。摇滚乐，我在唱歌。我心想，别再这样对我了。我们不能跳过我喜欢称之为“敏捷菲利斯”的片段。
Yes. she's so nimble. She's agile. She's quick. I mean, Andy tries to open her drawer. Phyllis does the no look slam. Yeah. Push back. Yeah. I mean, that's some quick reflexes, Phyllis. Yeah. Because Andy is looking for it everywhere. He cannot find it anywhere. Well, while Andy's looking for his phone, Angela goes into Michael's office, like Pam suggested, and she says, listen, the reason Dwight was late that morning was because, because he was dropping off the quarterly tax forms that she forgot to send. And to be fair, Kevin never reminded her. She just wants Michael to know that if Kevin had done his job, she could have done her job better. But that Dwight was saving the day.
是的。她太敏捷了。她很灵活。她很快。我是说，安迪试图打开她的抽屉。菲利斯做了个不看一眼的猛关。是的。推回去。是的。我是说，那反应真快，菲利斯。是的，因为安迪到处在找它。他哪儿也找不到。好吧，当安迪在找他的手机时，安吉拉走进迈克尔的办公室，就像帕姆建议的那样，她说，听着，德怀特那天早上迟到的原因是，因为他在送她忘了寄的季度税表。而且公平地说，凯文从来没提醒过她。她只是想让迈克尔知道，如果凯文做了他的工作，她就能更好地完成她的工作。但德怀特是在救场。
He wasn't going for some weird corporate power grab. He was doing this favor for her. Yes. I remember in this scene, Greg gave me the note to, you know, I'm coming in there. I'm very nervous because I really don't. want people in the office to know my business. I don't want them to know who I'm dating. Even though I really care for Dwight, I just hate the idea of being office gossip, you know? Yeah. So I'm going in there and he said, Angela, just deliver those lines at the top. Like, you're just quickly spilling it all out, you know? Yeah. So that's why I went in with that energy of just like, like, if she didn't say it right away, she was going to lose her nerve. So I was like, Dwight went to New York. You dropped off the text of her first. Like, you know, just kind of like, you know, just kind of like, it out. Yes.
他不是为了什么奇怪的公司权力争夺。他是在帮她的忙。是的。我记得在这个场景中，格雷格给了我提示，你知道，我走进去。我非常紧张，因为我真的不。想让办公室里的人知道我的私事。我不想让他们知道我在和谁约会。尽管我真的很关心德怀特，但我只是讨厌成为办公室八卦的想法，你知道吗？是的。所以我走进去，他说，安吉拉，就在开头说出那些台词。就像，你只是很快地把它全倒出来，你知道吗？是的。所以这就是为什么我带着那种能量走进去，就像，如果她不马上说出来，她就会失去勇气。所以我说，德怀特去了纽约。你先送了税表。就像，你知道，就像，把它说出来。是的。
And then, thank God, Michael is such an idiot. He doesn't connect the dots. He's like, oh, my God, Dwight, if he would do that for anyone in this office, who else is like that, you know? Yes. And I'm like, no one. And Angela's so happy. She's so happy.
然后，谢天谢地，迈克尔是个白痴。他没把点连起来。他说，噢，天哪，德怀特，如果他会为办公室里的任何人那样做，还有谁是这样的，你知道吗？是的。我说，没有别人。安吉拉太高兴了。她太高兴了。
She was able to sort of set the record straight without revealing their relationship. Yes. Michael just takes this as a sign of Dwight's undying loyalty to the conversation. to the company. Yeah. So he's like, I have to go get him back. I have to go get him back. Yeah.
她能够澄清事实，而没有暴露他们的关系。是的。迈克尔只是把这当作德怀特对公司无限忠诚的标志。对公司。是的。所以他说，我必须把他找回来。我必须把他找回来。是的。
But as he's on his way out the door, Andy, like, jumps in front of him and pitches him like this weekend date that they're going to go on. He's like, blurts out a gazillion things. And Michael is like, just stop, stop. You're driving me crazy. And Andy is like, oh, I'm sorry if my friendship. is annoying you. Sorry, I annoyed you with my friendship. Oh, that's what it is.
但当他正要出门时，安迪跳到他面前，向他推销他们这个周末要去的约会。他就像，脱口而出了一大堆事情。迈克尔说，停，停。你快把我逼疯了。安迪说，噢，如果我的友谊让你烦恼，我很抱歉。抱歉我用我的友谊烦扰了你。噢，就是这个。
That's what it is. Well, we had a fan question from Allie White. She wanted to know if that list of activities was scripted or improvised by Ed Helms. Guys, it was all scripted. Ed memorized to that. That was not an improvisation. It was perfect because they all sounded like a horrible evening. And Michael's like, I don't want to do any of those things.
就是这个。好吧，我们有一个来自艾莉·怀特的粉丝问题。她想知道那个活动清单是剧本写的还是艾德·赫尔姆斯即兴发挥的。伙计们，全是剧本写的。艾德背下了那个。那不是即兴发挥。这很完美，因为它们听起来都像是一个糟糕的夜晚。迈克尔说，我不想做任何那些事情。
So now Andy's phone starts ringing. So he's just been rejected publicly in front of the whole bullpen by Michael. And now his phone is ringing again, and the man snaps. He loses it. Yes. And this is what we talked about with Ed, where he had to punch a hole in the wall. And Angela, I reached out to Kent to find out exactly how many walls we had prepared for this stunt. And it was...
所以现在安迪的手机开始响了。所以他刚刚在整个办公区被迈克尔公开拒绝了。现在他的手机又响了，那个人崩溃了。他失控了。是的。这就是我们和艾德谈过的，他必须在墙上打个洞。安吉拉，我联系了肯特，想确切知道我们为这个特技准备了多少面墙。结果是……
How many? Four. So we could have done four, but remember, Ed thought they only had to do it twice, but there were four chances. So that's why when we were talking with Ed, I was like, my memory of this scene was that we all had to have our, you know, game face on. So we didn't ruin one of these takes. We only had four walls, everybody. Well, I noticed in the reaction pass in the accounting department, there's one reaction pass where Oscar is standing and then it cuts back and he's like seated and then it cuts back in. So it was like, it didn't quite match up.
多少？四面。所以我们本来可以拍四次，但记住，艾德以为他们只需要拍两次，但有四次机会。所以这就是为什么当我们和艾德谈话时，我说，我对这个场景的记忆是我们都必须拿出我们的，你知道，比赛状态。所以我们没有毁掉这些拍摄中的任何一个。我们只有四面墙，各位。好吧，我注意到在会计部门的反应镜头中，有一个反应镜头是奥斯卡站着，然后切回来，他坐着，然后又切回来。所以它有点，不太匹配。
But my kids loved that. They were like, Oscar sitting, Oscar standing, Oscar sitting. And while all of this is happening, the thing they really were tickled by is that the Homer Simpson doll was turned sideways with like his butt in the air. Oh, Homer fell over. Homer fell over. And then we had to go back and look for when Homer was upright and he was on his side, pretty much the whole episode, just so you guys know.
但我的孩子们喜欢那个。他们说，奥斯卡坐着，奥斯卡站着，奥斯卡坐着。而在这一切发生的同时，真正让他们感到高兴的是，荷马·辛普森玩偶被侧着放，屁股朝天。噢，荷马倒了。荷马倒了。然后我们不得不回去看荷马什么时候是直立的，他几乎整集都在侧着，只是让你们知道。
Oh, guys, the name of this episode is Homer fell over. and snow and sadness. So now we go outside and Michael is in the parking lot and his car has filled with snow. How's he going to get in it? He's got to like shovel it out. He's rushing, but he has to dig the snow out first. Angela, I have a wonderful tidbit about this snow.
噢，伙计们，这一集的名字是“荷马倒了”和“雪与悲伤”。所以现在我们走到外面，迈克尔在停车场，他的车里装满了雪。他怎么进去？他得把它铲出来。他在赶时间，但他必须先挖出雪。安吉拉，关于这些雪我有一个很棒的小花絮。
What? Okay. Kent told me the same snow company filled that seabring with fake snow. But it wasn't icy snow. It was like the little plastic flakes because there's lots of different kinds of fake. snow. So they were these little plastic flakes. And at the end of the shoot day, it took them the entire next day to vacuum all of the snow out. And that was a rental. They rented that car. They had to get all that out of there. Yeah. And at the end of the season, they kept it for the whole year. At the end of the season, when they returned it, the snow was still in like the inner workings of the car. He said whenever
什么？好吧。肯特告诉我，同一家雪公司用假雪填满了那辆赛百灵。但那不是冰雪。那是像小塑料片一样的东西，因为假雪有很多种。所以它们是这些小塑料片。在拍摄结束时，他们花了整整第二天的时间才把所有的雪吸出来。而且那是租来的。他们租了那辆车。他们必须把所有东西都弄出来。是的。而在季末，他们保留了它一整年。在季末，当他们归还它时，雪还在车的内部结构里。他说每当
they would turn on the AC, snow would blow out of the vent. Oh, gosh. They never could get all the snow out. And I think they had to pay a fee when they returned it. I'm sure they did. I'm sure they did because someone is going to rent it, turn on the air, and these little fake pieces of plastic snow are going to fly out at them. Yes. I loved that tidbit. I loved that every time we tried to turn on the AC, snow would come out of there. Well, Michael has now, he's at Staples. He's going to go up to Dwight. He's going to I apologize. He wants him to come back. And I love the scene so much. I mean, Dwight is tearing up. It is a very bromance moment. Well, yes. That is what Greg calls it. He calls it the bromance moment. And, you know, playing underneath the scene is the song from an officer and a gentleman. Yes. Remember at the end of Officer and a Gentleman where she's in the factory working and Richard Gere, walks in and he scoops her up and they kiss and everyone cheers. It's what is it? It's love lift us up where we belong. Yes. Yes. Where the eagles fly the whole thing. Well, there is like a musac version of this playing at Staples during this scene. It's amazing. Guys, Greg sent in an audio clip talking about this bromance. The ending of the return was, like the big bromance moment between Michael and Dwight. I'm pretty sure the officer and a gentleman
他们打开空调，雪就会从通风口吹出来。噢，天哪。他们永远无法把所有的雪都弄出来。而且我想他们在归还时不得不支付一笔费用。我肯定他们付了。我肯定他们付了，因为有人会租它，打开空调，这些小小的假塑料雪片就会飞出来。是的。我喜欢那个花絮。我喜欢我们每次试图打开空调时，雪就会从里面出来。好吧，迈克尔现在到了，他在史泰博。他要去找德怀特。他要道歉。他想让他回来。我太喜欢这个场景了。我是说，德怀特在流泪。这是一个非常“兄弟情”的时刻。好吧，是的。这就是格雷格称呼它的方式。他称之为“兄弟情”时刻。而且，你知道，在场景下播放的是《军官与绅士》里的那首歌。是的。记得《军官与绅士》结尾，她在工厂工作，理查·基尔走进来，他抱起她，他们接吻，每个人都在欢呼。是什么？是“爱让我们升华到属于我们的地方”。是的。是的。老鹰飞翔的地方，整件事。好吧，在这一幕中，史泰博里播放着这首歌的轻音乐版本。太神奇了。伙计们，格雷格发来了一段音频片段谈论这段兄弟情。这一集的结尾，就像迈克尔和德怀特之间的大兄弟情时刻。我很确定《军官与绅士》
was in the script to begin with. As I recall, we were building towards that moment to see Michael going through the aisles at Staples and trying to, you know, make a big romantic moment out of it, like Richard Gear returning for Devere Winger. And that is exactly what it is. I really wish Rain had picked Steve up and told him around. I wish that had been in the script. Well, Rain is Deborah Winger in this scenario, though. I know, but he's bigger than Steve, so I think it would be, like, that's how they, instead of them disappearing, like, with him taking his staples uniform off, that he just carries Michael out. Anyway. Well, speaking of his uniform, when Dwight comes back to the party at Dunder Mifflin,
本来就在剧本里。据我回忆，我们正在为那一刻做铺垫，看迈克尔穿过史泰博的过道，试图，你知道，把它变成一个浪漫的大时刻，就像理查·基尔回来找黛博拉·温格一样。而这正是它的样子。我真希望雷恩抱起史蒂夫并转动他。我希望那能在剧本里。好吧，虽然在这个场景中雷恩是黛博拉·温格。我知道，但他比史蒂夫大，所以我认为那会是，就像，那是他们的方式，而不是他们消失，就像，他脱掉史泰博制服，而是他直接把迈克尔抱走了。无论如何。好吧，说到他的制服，当德怀特回到邓德·米夫林的派对时，
he's wearing a Battlestar Galactica sweatshirt, right? Yeah. Okay, you know what about this? That Battlestar Galactica did not have any sweatshirt merchandise. Isn't that insane? Yeah. So our wardrobe designer Carrie Bennett had to make up a Battlestar Galactica merch sweatshirt for Dwight to wear. Yes, they made it special. It doesn't exist. I texted Rain and asked him if he still has it.
他穿着一件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的运动衫，对吧？是的。好吧，你知道关于这个的什么吗？《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》没有任何运动衫周边。这不疯狂吗？是的。所以我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特不得不为德怀特制作一件《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的周边运动衫来穿。是的，他们特别制作的。它不存在。我给雷恩发了短信，问他是否还留着它。
Oh, please tell me. He said he did. He doesn't, and he super regrets not snatching it. Oh, that would have been a good one to snatch. I know. I know. Someone has it. It's the one and only. Well, you know, when Dwight comes back in the office, I remember I have this moment where I'm talking to Oscar.
噢，请告诉我。他说他留着。他不留了，他非常后悔没把它抢过来。噢，那会是一个抢过来的好东西。我知道。我知道。有人留着它。它是独一无二的。好吧，你知道，当德怀特回到办公室时，我记得我有这个时刻，我在和奥斯卡说话。
And Greg was like, when he walks in the room, I want Angela Martin in the moment to sort of let her guard down. You know, so I'm blatantly looking at him with such, like, love in my eyes. and happiness, and, you know, we're still reserved. We just shake hands, right? Yeah. But there's so much emotion, like, between the two of us and Michael's just oblivious. But then you shake hands with him. You welcome him back with a handshake.
格雷格说，当他走进房间时，我希望安吉拉·马丁在那个时刻能放下她的防备。你知道，所以我公然地看着他，眼里充满了爱和幸福，而且，你知道，我们仍然很矜持。我们只是握手，对吧？是的。但我们俩之间有太多的情感，而迈克尔只是浑然不觉。但然后你和他握手。你用握手欢迎他回来。
Yes. Now, I need to ask you a question, Angela. Mm-hmm. Have you not been in touch? I mean, you guys aren't seeing one another outside of the office? You don't go to each other's homes, talk on the phone. I think so, but I think he was miserable at his job. And I was the reason he wasn't at the job he wanted to be at and to see him come back in the office and to know that he's back where he wants to be.
是的。现在，我需要问你一个问题，安吉拉。嗯哼。你们没有联系吗？我是说，你们在办公室外不见面吗？你们不去对方家里，不打电话？我想是这样，但我认为他在工作中很痛苦。而我就是他没能在那个他想待的岗位上工作的原因，看到他回到办公室，知道他回到了他想待的地方。
And it's so layered what he did for me. And then the risk I took going to Michael, all that emotion is playing out in that moment. Yeah. It's not that it's the first time you guys have seen each other. other in a month. It's that he's back where he belongs. Yes. And we both made sacrifices for each other. Right. And so it sort of takes our relationship to this next place. I think very subtly of like, he did that for me. And I went out of my comfort zone and did this thing for him. And he knows it. And I know it. Right. So I think it's that. But of course, Michael's oblivious. And we
而且他为我所做的一切是如此有层次。然后我去找迈克尔所冒的风险，所有的情感都在那一刻爆发。是的。并不是说这是你们一个月来第一次见面。而是他回到了他属于的地方。是的。而且我们都为彼此做出了牺牲。对。所以它把我们的关系带到了下一个阶段。我认为非常微妙，就像，他为我做了那个。而我走出了我的舒适区，为他做了这件事。他知道。我也知道。对。所以我认为就是那样。但当然，迈克尔浑然不觉。我们
look at each other with love in our eyes and shake hands. And then that's it. The party is well underway, though, lady. Yeah. While we're shaking hands and doing all this, everyone's having a good time. And Jenna, we have a fantastic Phyllis dance catch. Yes. Michael says to Pam, hey, Pam, shake yours and I'll shake. And she's like, no.
眼里带着爱看着对方，握了握手。然后就是这样。派对正在进行中，女士。是的。当我们握手做这一切时，每个人都玩得很开心。而且珍娜，我们有一个精彩的菲利斯舞蹈发现。是的。迈克尔对帕姆说，嘿，帕姆，摇动你的，我会摇动。她说，不。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm not going to do that. But guess who's so, like, delighted. Phyllis at 25 minutes, 18 seconds, you guys know that Phyllis was a burless dancer. And you are seeing a straight up real deal burles. burlesque shimmy in the background by Phyllis. I'll tell you what, that shimmy was not in the script. Oh, of course not.
是的。是的，我不会那样做。但猜猜谁，就像，很高兴。菲利斯在25分18秒，你们知道菲利斯曾经是一名滑稽舞者。你正在看到菲利斯在背景中跳出一段纯正的、真正的滑稽舞摇摆。我告诉你，那个摇摆不在剧本里。噢，当然不在。
So I don't know where we got that, but I think Phyllis just improvised that in the moment. Any chance to dance, Phyllis is in. Yeah. But also, I just want to say, Angela, I want to point out this party's going great that Angela didn't plan. That's all. I'm sorry. She was there. She was just sort of zoned out.
所以我不知道我们从哪儿弄来的，但我认为菲利斯只是在那个时刻即兴发挥了。任何跳舞的机会，菲利斯都会加入。是的。但我也想说，安吉拉，我想指出这个派对进行得很棒，而安吉拉并没有计划。就是这样。我很抱歉。她在那里。她只是有点走神了。
But she was part of the planning. I know, but it's just maybe we should take note of what a great party it is. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my God. Well, I titled the next scene, Oof. We have another Oof? The scene is just called Oof. This was Heartbreak in the Break Room, was titled Oof.
但她是计划的一部分。我知道，但也许我们应该注意这是一个多么棒的派对。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。好吧，我把下一个场景命名为“哎呀”。我们又有另一个“哎呀”？这个场景就叫“哎呀”。这是“休息室里的心碎”，被命名为“哎呀”。
This is Heartbreak in the Conference Room. Yeah, so here's what happens, you guys. Karen and Jim, they're sitting side by side in the conference room. They're not even talking or. are looking at each other. They're not even looking at each other. That's the, even the saddest, like, ugh, part is that when he says he's still in the pan... He won't even look her in the eye.
这是“会议室里的心碎”。是的，所以发生了什么，伙计们。凯伦和吉姆，他们并排坐在会议室里。他们甚至没有说话或看着对方。他们甚至没有看着对方。那是，甚至最悲伤的，就像，呃，部分是当他说他还在帕姆……他甚至不看她的眼睛。
Yeah. She just gets up and walks away. She's like, yeah. F this. Yeah, because she says, do you still have feelings for her? Mm-hmm. And he says, yeah. And I just want to say, Jim, yes, wishy-washy, Jim is gone.
是的。她只是站起来走开了。她就像，是的。去你的。是的，因为她说，你还对她有感觉吗？嗯哼。他说，是的。我只想说，吉姆，是的，优柔寡断的吉姆不见了。
and we have real Jim back again. Jim is back and he's owning his feelings. Yes, we're happy. So this episode ends with Dwight, who thinks the party is for him, by the way, even though the sign says, Welcome Back Oscar. There's three signs.
我们又找回了真正的吉姆。吉姆回来了，他正在正视自己的感受。是的，我们很高兴。所以这一集以德怀特结束，顺便说一句，他认为派对是为他举办的，尽管牌子上写着“欢迎奥斯卡回来”。有三个牌子。
There's three signs that say, Welcome Back Oscar. But somehow Dwight is like, this party's for me. He gets to hit the pinata and he just destroys it, destroys it. He destroys it. Then he goes through the office, just whacking all the pinatas that were decorative pignatas hanging through the bullpen. In the DVD commentary for this episode, they talk about the fact that as Rain started hitting pignatas, Phil Shea was like, hold up, wait, wait, wait. I have duplicates for this one, this one, and this one. You cannot hit that one or
有三个牌子写着“欢迎奥斯卡回来”。但不知何故，德怀特觉得“这个派对是为我举办的”。他去打皮纳塔，他直接摧毁了它，摧毁了它。他摧毁了它。然后他穿过办公室，猛击挂在办公区的所有装饰性皮纳塔。在这一集的DVD评论中，他们谈到了这样一个事实：当雷恩开始打皮纳塔时，菲尔·谢说，等等，等等，等等。我有这个、这个和这个的复制品。你不能打那个或者
that one. Oh my gosh. So when you see Rain kind of like running through, he had like a little roadmap of which pinata he could hit and he couldn't hit. So if you see him run right past a perfectly good pinata, it's because we didn't have a duplicate for it. So we had to run across to another one and whack it. These are the details people don't know that actors have in their brains when they're doing a scene. Yeah. We only have one more thing to talk about, Angela, which is Andy is going to anger management. And he's going to crush it. It's supposed to be 10 weeks. He's going to knock it out in five. He has a whole plan. Through his usual name, repetition, personality, mirroring, and positive reinforcement through nods and smiles. He's going to do this
那个。噢，天哪。所以当你看到雷恩跑过时，他有一张小路线图，知道他能打哪个，不能打哪个。所以如果你看到他跑过一个完好的皮纳塔，那是因为我们没有它的复制品。所以我们不得不跑到另一个去猛击它。这些是演员在做场景时脑子里有的细节，人们不知道。是的。我们只有一个问题要谈，安吉拉，那就是安迪要去参加愤怒管理课程。他会表现得很棒。本来应该是10周。他要在5周内完成。他有一个完整的计划。通过他通常的名字重复、个性镜像，以及通过点头和微笑进行积极强化。他要在
in five weeks. And in fact, he does do it in five weeks. Ed, the character of Andy is gone for the next five episodes, and then he returns. And we had a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Chelsea Lane, Aaron Westra, Amanda Jerson, Brianna Kernan, Kaylee Waiting, all asked, Did Ed Helms have to be written out because he had to film something else? No. No, we had asked Ed about this, so I don't know if you guys remember back in Gay Witch Hunt when I had talked to Ed about how he came to be on the show. Remember, he said he was originally only hired for a short period of time,
5周内完成。事实上，他确实在5周内完成了。艾德，安迪这个角色在接下来的5集里消失了，然后他回来了。我们有很多关于这个的粉丝问题，安吉拉。切尔西·莱恩、亚伦·韦斯特拉、阿曼达·杰森、布里安娜·科南、凯莉·韦廷，都问，艾德·赫尔姆斯必须被写走是因为他必须去拍别的东西吗？不。不，我们问过艾德这件事，所以我不知道你们是否还记得在《同性恋猎巫》中，我谈到艾德是如何来到这个节目的。记得吗，他说他最初只被雇佣了很短的一段时间，
and it wasn't until later that they decided to end. add him as a series regular? Well, I guess, Angela, how did he explain it? He said that by the time they decided to make him a series regular, they had actually written all of the episodes to finish out his initial little contract. And this episode was supposed to end with Andy punching the wall and being fired and never coming back again. Yeah, in this episode, we basically lose Andy and then we're soon going to lose Karen, right? And that would have wrapped up all. all of the Stanford extra character storylines, but everyone just fell in love with Ed and just how Andy was the perfect foil for Dwight, and they wanted him back, and they had to
直到后来他们才决定结束。让他成为常规角色？嗯，我想，安吉拉，他是怎么解释的？他说，当他们决定让他成为常规角色时，他们实际上已经写完了他最初那份小合同里的所有剧集。而这一集原本应该以安迪打墙被解雇且再也不会回来而结束。是的，在这一集中，我们基本上失去了安迪，然后很快我们又要失去凯伦了，对吧？那本可以结束所有斯坦福额外角色的故事线，但每个人都爱上了艾德，以及安迪作为德怀特完美陪衬的方式，他们想让他回来，所以他们不得不
sort of figure that out. How does that work? What does that contract look like? We already have these scripts without him. So they sorted it all out in five weeks, and Andy comes back. Yes, and it was so, so great. And in the meantime, I remember that they were wanting to also keep Rashida around a little bit longer, but she ends up getting a job on Parks and Rec. Yes.
想办法解决这个问题。那是怎么运作的？那份合同是什么样的？我们已经有了没有他的剧本。所以他们在五周内解决了所有问题，安迪回来了。是的，这真是太棒了。与此同时，我记得他们也想让拉什达多留一会儿，但她最终在《公园与游憩》找到了一份工作。是的。
Yeah. Which stays sort of in the office family, which is really fun. Yes, because Parks and Recreation was created together by Greg Daniels and Mike Scher. Yep. Well, lady, before we say goodbye to the return, did you happen to catch what the anger means? management class, what the name of the company was? No. I loved it so much.
是的。这仍然算是“办公室”大家庭的一部分，这真的很有趣。是的，因为《公园与游憩》是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克·舒尔共同创作的。没错。好吧，女士，在我们告别《回归》这一集之前，你有没有注意到“愤怒管理课”中那家公司的名字是什么？没有。我太喜欢那个名字了。
It's on the door as they go in. What is it? Calm visions. Oh. You know what? I'm already less angry. Are you having calm visions? I am.
他们进去的时候门上写着。是什么？“平静愿景”。哦。你知道吗？我已经没那么生气了。你有“平静愿景”吗？我有。
I am. Done. Well, that was the return, everybody. Thank you so much for listening. A big thank you to Ed Helms for being our guest and Greg Daniels. And as always, Kent Sabornaq, Kintapedia. And, you know, Jenna and I, we reach out to people like crazy if it's as simple as like a text to creed to jog his memory or I, I DM'd a vet. Like, I'm just always so appreciative by how many people, Jenna, respond in a timely manner and get back to us and help us make these podcasts happen.
我有。完成了。好吧，这就是《回归》这一集，大家。非常感谢大家的收听。非常感谢我们的嘉宾艾德·赫尔姆斯和格雷格·丹尼尔斯。还有一如既往的肯特·萨博纳克，肯特百科。而且，你知道，珍娜和我，我们疯狂地联系人们，有时候只是给克里德发条短信来唤起他的记忆，或者我给艾德发了私信。珍娜，我总是非常感激有这么多人能及时回复我们，帮助我们完成这些播客。
Well, listen, guys, we will see you next week with one of my favorite episodes, Ben Franklin. Ben Franklin. We'll see you then. I love Ben Franklin so much. We'll talk about it next week. All right. Bye, everyone. Have a good one. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
好吧，听着，伙计们，我们下周见，届时将播出我最喜欢的剧集之一，《本·富兰克林》。本·富兰克林。到时候见。我太喜欢《本·富兰克林》了。我们下周再聊。好的。再见，大家。祝你们过得愉快。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯饮品。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。